in this course you will learn how to
build cross-platform desktop
applications in Python that can run on
Windows Mac and Linux this course will
teach you the fundamentals of working
with QT to build GUI applications using
pi side 6. Daniel gakuaya developed this
course Daniela is an experienced
software engineer and he's the creator
of our most viewed course of the last
year
hello guys and welcome to this new
course on Pi side sex in this course I
will show you how to use Python and Pi
side 6 to World great graphical user
interfaces that run on desktop that's
Windows Mac and Linux and you will be
writing your code once and all you have
to do is to run your python application
on a different operating system and
that's going to run seamlessly so that's
the point of the course here building
cross-platform graphical user interfaces
applications using QT under the pi side
sex umbrella Pi side 6 is really a
technology that allows you to mix up
Python and QT to take advantage of the
foundation that QT provides and I may
hear some of you asking what is QT well
QT is a cross-platform framework to
build a graphical user interface
applications but it is originally
written in the C plus plus and the pi
side 6 is a project that aims to give us
the ability to to take advantage of what
QT provides using the Python programming
language and this is really cool if you
are a python developer you can take
advantage of what QT offers without
needing to learn C plus plus and that's
a huge Advantage you might want to take
advantage of in your career as a python
developer so this course aims at giving
you the ability to build applications
like notepad here you see it is a
graphical user interface it has a bunch
of menus and toolbars we have a status
bar here we can type text here this is
one of the applications we will get a
chance to build and this is going to
give you a foundation to really build
any kind of application you might want
in your career as a python developer
another great aspect of this course is
that we try to take advantage of every
opportunity to teach you how to use the
documentation so if you want to search
for something for example Pi site 6 and
Q widget
okay you can come to your favorite
search engine and search here you will
have the information on this component
and you can learn about it we will be
doing this a lot in the course and I
hope this is going to give you the
ability to even learn more on your own
because I can't really show you
everything in a course like this but
this is going to give you a great
Foundation to build your own work on top
of the requirements for the course are
not really that bad all you need is a
basic python understanding if you can
work with variables functions if you can
work with basic object oriented
programming if you know things like
classes inheritance you will have a good
time with the course the most important
thing is really the strong drive and
willingness to learn so if you have a
roadblock for example if there is
something you don't understand
you should have the drive to actually
try and go in a search engine put that
in a search bar and really try to
understand what is going on once you
understand that you can come back to the
course but you are not on your own we
have a community on Discord you can join
to be together with other people that
are going through the course if you post
a question there I will try and help the
best I can and if you go through this
course you will have a strong Foundation
to build graphical user interfaces using
pi side 6. this is going to give you the
ability to build graphical user
interfaces for your existing python
projects so if you are an existing
python developer this is going to be a
great asset for your career another
thing is that the knowledge you get in
this course is transferable so if you
learn to build the graphical user
interfaces using buy side sex the
knowledge you gain is going to also be
useful if you later choose to use
another toolkit for example there is
another project which is called the pi
cutie which also allows you to build the
QT applications using python so if you
go through the course here you will have
the ability to take advantage of that
framework pretty fast because the API is
the same but the ideas on graphical user
interfaces aren't really tied to a
single graphical user interface toolkit
so once you've learned the foundations
you can use other toolkits fairly easily
okay so now that you know a bit about
the course let's talk about myself here
my name is Daniel acquire I am a
software engineer I have been using QT
for a lot of years and I happen to have
a few courses on QT on udemy most of
these courses are using C plus plus but
I release the new course which is using
cute for python but don't feel pressured
to take that course if you want you can
take it but this one on YouTube is going
to give you enough to build a lot of
things and once you have that knowledge
you can go on and use the documentation
to even learn more than I can tell you
in a course like this this is really all
I had to share in this lecture so let's
stop here and start learning about pie
side sex in the next lecture go ahead
and finish up here and meet me there I
would like to welcome you in this course
and congratulate you on taking a step to
become a better cute for python
developer cute is a cross-platform
application development framework you
can use it to write applications for
Windows Mac Linux Android iOS and even
embedded devices the way QT works you
write your code once and recompile it
for your Target platform so for example
if you write your application on Windows
if you wanted to generate a Linux binary
what you need to do is to recompile your
code on a Linux machine and that's going
to give you a binary that can run on
Linux you can repeat the process on the
Mac and that's going to drastically
reduce your development time because you
basically write your code once and run
it or recompile it for whatever Target
where you want to run your application
now python is one of the official
languages we can use to develop cute
applications the main language for QT is
currently C plus plus but python is
quickly catching up under the umbrella
of QT for python or Pi side 6 as it is
currently known again going through
python you can write applications that
are cross-platforms that run on Windows
Linux and Mac but currently support for
mobile and embedded is in development I
wouldn't really use this in production
but there should be good progress in
this area in the future now if you talk
about Pi side sex some people are going
to mention Pi QT what about by QT
piquity is another Library which is
available to let you write QT
applications using the Python
programming language and it can mostly
do the same things we can do with pi
side 6 but Pi side 6 has probably a
better future because it is under the
official QT project so you can expect
support for things like Android and iOS
to go faster than Pi QT another thing is
that to use piquity in a commercial
application and you need to buy a
separate license for pi QT and you also
need to buy another license for QT so if
you really want to drive your cost down
it is beneficial to use Pi side because
you will be buying the license once
which is going to include the QT and Pi
side sex so that's something for you to
consider but I'm going to leave the
decision to you whether you use Pi QT
and Pi side this course is not going to
cover up iqt but the good news is that
once you have Pi side 6 mastered it is
going to be very fast to pick up Pi QT
because the apis are mostly similar
what's going to change is what you
import in your python files and you will
be basically able to do the same thing
so whether you use 5qt or Pi side 6
that's going to be your choice but we
will be focusing on Pi side 6 and the
API should help you to pick up iqt if
you happen to need that now let's head
over to the QT page on Wikipedia and see
some information about QT it is a
cross-platform application development
framework you can use to write
applications for Android iOS Linux you
can see a lot of things here you can
write applications for using QT it was
developed by these two guys Harvard and
Eric and it is currently developed by
the QT Company the company owning
licenses of QT it is written in C plus
plus and what I want you to see is a
bunch of applications that are written
in QT to kind of give you an idea of
what you can do if you learn a QT
properly if you go down here you see
Autodesk Maya which is a popular
application for building 3D stuff we can
go down and find the Creator here which
is a design software you can use to do
painting and drawing things like that
you can say Mathematica if you are a
scientist you must know this you can see
OBS here which is what I am using to
record this video you can see Cube bit
torrent you can use to download torrents
and things it's like that there are
really powerful applications that are
written in QT you can see VLC media
player you can see WPS office which is
really cool if you wanted to do some
office stuff and if you go down you will
find a bunch of organizations that are
using QT and there are some big names in
here you can see AMD you can see
blizzard you can see DreamWorks you can
see Panasonic Phillips you can see CMS
and Samsung you can see Tesla there's a
lot of big companies using QT and this
should give you an idea of how powerful
QT really is and you can be in the same
league as these companies and these
pieces of software if you learn to
develop applications with QT properly
and this course is a perfect starting
point if you want to use Python to
develop cute widgets applications okay
one thing I want you to know is that
there are two apis when it comes to
developing QT applications there is the
cute widgets API AI which provides
components you can use to build
graphical user interfaces for desktop
this is mainly targeted for desktop
platforms mainly Windows Linux and Mac
but there is a new API which is called
qml which also includes new devices like
mobile devices and embedded devices and
you can use this to build Dynamic and
fluid graphical user interfaces that
look modern and really feel like they
are from our time here but make no
mistake qml applications can also run on
desktop so you will need to do some
research to decide whether you want to
use cute Widgets or qml but if you
exclusively want to Target a desktop I
would still recommend using cute widgets
because it is a mature API it is tested
it has been in use since the 1990s and
it is really powerful so use that if you
don't care about mobile or embedded if
you want to Target mobile and embedded
please use qml in it is best suited for
that and one thing I want to point out
is that this course is about cute
widgets if you are interested in qml
please check out other courses we have
on qml because this course is not
talking about qml I wanted that to be
super clear now if you decide to use QT
to build your applications regardless of
whether you are using widgets for Q
amount you will be writing your logic in
some programming language and the two
official languages that are supported by
the QT company or the cute projects in
general is python which we will be
covering in this course year and C plus
plus but this course as I said is about
using python to develop cute widgets
applications so this is going to be our
Focus here using python to write cute
widgets application that can run on
Windows Mac and Linux another thing I
would like you to know is that cute is
not just about graphical user interfaces
many people can mistake it for that cute
can can be used for much more if you
happen to be using QT already for a
graphical user interface you still have
a window to take advantage of even more
things from the QT framework you can do
networking you can do threading you can
write database applications you can use
tons of other utility classes that are
provided by QT so if you are already
using QT take some time to see some
other things you can take advantage of
in this course I will touch on some
networking and show you how you can do
some basic HTTP stuff but that's not
enough to really call yourself a network
developer using QT if you want to really
go deep you will need to do more
research but this course should give you
a good foundation on which to build even
more cool stuff now this course is going
to be a perfect starting point for you
if you want to build graphical user
interfaces in Python using pi side 6
obviously but I think it is even going
to give you a good foundation even if
you plan to use them out if you are new
to the QT ecosystem I usually recommend
shredding by cute widgets which is what
we cover in this course and from there
you will grasp the fundamentals of how
to use QT to write cross-platform
applications and that's going to really
be easy for you to do that because you
will be writing your applications on
desktop you will be able to generate
applications that run on the same
machine where you are sitting once you
have the fundamentals you can Venture
into qml and the same fundamentals you
get from cute widgets are going to apply
more or less in qml qml is a declarative
language and that makes it easy to pick
up by designers but this course is about
cute widgets using Python and it is
going to give you the fundamentals that
are going to help you out even if later
you decide to use qml that's the point I
am trying to make here now I will be
preparing this course on a Windows
machine but that's not going to be a
problem because Python and high side 6
run where both on Windows Linux and Mac
so you can watch what I do on Windows
and try to adapt that to your operating
system and that's going to work really
well don't worry about that this course
is going to work for you whether you are
on Windows Linux or Mac the requirements
for this course are not really that hard
all I require is a basic understanding
of Python and the basic understanding of
object-oriented programming in Python if
you can use things like classes objects
inheritance and polymorphism you will
probably be fine with the course using
python here the most important thing in
my opinion is the strong drive and
willingness to learn which is going to
go a long way if you come along problems
you won't give up easily you will keep
trying until you get to the thing
running here but I will do my best to
explain everything I use in the course
if you need a refresher on python please
note this course is going to assume you
already know python so make sure you
learn python first before you take all
discourse now this is all I had to cover
in this video here I hope you found it
interesting and you are encouraged and
excited to learn about Pi side six we
are going to head over in the next
lecture and show you some of the cool
applications you get to build as you go
through the course here go ahead and
finish up here and meet me there in this
lecture we're going to see how you can
get the most out of the course here and
there is really no magic build you can
take to get to the knowledge from the
course Detroit and true way is to follow
along watch the videos try to practice
the things I do in the course try to
modify the code and make it yours and
that's really how you are going to get
the mask out of the course here another
thing I would recommend is to use the QT
examples so if you go to the browser for
example and search for QT examples I
think they have a lot of examples you
can browse to this link they will show
you tons and tons of examples and this
is a way you can get full running
applications you can try out most of
these are going to be for C plus plus
but once you have the fundamentals in
this course you will have the necessary
Basics to try and understand what is
going on here if you go down you see
examples for acute widgets for example
if we open the text editor example here
all the model view example people you
will see that you can build something
like this and this is something we even
built in our course here but that's
going to be in Python you can learn
about the model view architecture you
can really do all kinds of prison things
through these examples here so if you
have an idea come to the QT examples see
if there is something similar try to
build on top of that this is the best
way I can recommend to even learn QT by
yourself without even needing a course
like this but if you are a beginner the
documentation like this can be hard to
understand you still need the basics
this course is going to give you the
basics to allow you to take advantage of
this but start trying to browse through
these examples now see what you can pick
up or even identify the things you need
to focus on in the course here once you
have the knowledge you can come back and
use it another thing I recommend is to
use the source code that is going to be
provided in the course here the link is
going to be shared at each lecture so if
you want you can go to the lecture
download the source code and use that
however you want another thing I would
recommend is asking questions if you get
stuck the course platform will provide a
mechanism to ask questions so you can
ask a question I will try to respond as
best as I can so take advantage of that
if you get stuck we also have a bunch of
groups on Facebook and Discord you can
join and help each other out that's a
really good way to learn and to find
people who are going through the same
thing take advantage of all these
channels to make the most out of the
course here I want you to be successful
in using pi site 6 to build
cross-platform desktop applications now
that you know this it is time we headed
over to the next lecture and started
setting up the environment for building
Pi side 6 applications in no time go
ahead and finish up here and meet me
there
in this video we are going to set up the
environment that is going to allow us to
build cute for python applications or Pi
side 6 applications and the tools we
install should work on Windows Mac and
Linux because that's the essence of QT
QT is a cross-platform framework that
allows us to write applications once and
be able to build them on different
platforms and in this course we are
interested in building for Windows Mac
and Linux so here are the tools we are
going to need we will need an
installation of python once we have
python we will install Pi side 6 and we
will need an editor through which we
will be typing python or Pi side 6 code
later in the course we will need QT
designer but I am going to show you how
to install it later at that time for now
we will get into the process of
installing python Pi side 6 and the
editor that we are are going to be using
in this course here another thing I
should say is that you don't have to use
Visual Studio code it happens to be an
editor that I prefer because it's free
it's cross-platform it looks and feels
the same whether you are on Windows Mac
and Linux and I expect a lot of students
to be watching this course on a
different operating systems so visual
studio code is a good choice here okay
so let's start with python here if you
go to your search engine and type python
install we will go to the python.org
website and you will find binaries you
can download for whatever operating
system you are on so if you hit download
here you will download it and install it
like you install any other application
and when you are done installing python
you should be able to go to your
terminal whatever terminal you have
installed and say Python and if you see
a message like this it means that python
is installed on your system now we have
python installed let's set out of this
accept okay we are done here now that we
have python installed okay now that we
have python installed we need to install
Pi side six and to do that it's really
simple all you have to do is to open
your terminal here and use the PIP
package manager for python we will be
using version three here so let's say
pip 3 install Pi side six type this on
your terminal if you hit enter the tool
is going to go to work and it is going
to download and install Pi type 6 on
your system and at this point we will
have python at Pi side 6 installed on
our system the next thing we want to do
is to install an editor and as I said we
will be using visual studio code in this
course here so let's go back to our
search engine and say Visual Studio code
download this should spit out a link to
the website or Visual Studio code and
you can download and install for for
your operating system I am on windows at
this moment so I can download and
install it on Windows but you can do the
same whether you are on Linux or on a
Mac once you have this installed you
will need to open it up if you open it
it's going to look something like this
and the first thing I want you to do
once you have it installed is to install
a python extension that is going to make
our life easier when working with python
code and all you have to do is type a
python in the search bar here let's make
sure it is highlighted so everybody can
see it so we have this guy here and I
want you to choose the one that says
python here and I want you to choose the
one that says python here okay the one
from Microsoft if you click on it it's
going to say intellisense the LinkedIn
debugging for whatever in a visual
studio code you will click on install
and wait for it to be installed and at
that moment you will be ready to start
using Visual Studio code to develop cute
for python applications using pi site 6.
okay now that we have this installed
it's time to test it and see that it
actually works what we are going to do
is to open a folder on our system let's
go somewhere on my drive here I have a
folder it is an empty folder you can
name it whatever you want and if you go
in you're going to see that it is an
empty folder what we are going to do is
to drag and drop this on top of Visual
Studio code and this is going to open
the folder inside videos video code we
are going to get a window that says do
we trust this folder yes I trust this
because I created it so yes trust the
authors and we will have something on
the left here and this is going to be
where we see our files and this section
here is going to be the editor in which
we're going to be typing stuff so
nothing special here let's go on the
left and hover over these buttons here
you see we see one that says new file
another says new folder we want to click
on the one that says new file and in
this window we will type main.py for
python if we do that we will create a
python file here and all we need to do
is to put in Python code that is going
to attempt to use the pi side
installation we just brought into our
computer here okay so what we are going
to do is to put in some code to test
things out I don't really expect you to
understand everything we do here all we
want to do is to make sure that the
environment works we will have a chance
to learn about all the things we see in
this piece of code and even more so
let's put in an import statement and
this is just going to import Q
application and Q widget and these are
classes we're going to be using to
create our widgets application after
that we can go down and say import sys
and this is going to import a facility
that allows us to work with command line
options in Python if you know python you
probably know about command line options
we can go down and create a variable app
and we're going to say Q application and
assists args and after that we will
create a window
and it's going to be a q winner
we will show the window and after that
we will start the application by calling
the exec method okay now that we have
this we can try to run it but before we
do please make sure you have exactly the
same thing as I do here I would even
recommend going to the GitHub repository
for the course and copying and pasting
this entire code here because at this
point you may not be familiar with these
things like Q application Q widget and
some people are going to introduce typos
and have unnecessary frustrations so I
do recommend using the code AS is here
so you can copy from the GitHub
repository and paste in here okay once
you have the code in make sure you save
so you can control s on this or file and
save and after this we will open a
terminal window we're going to come to
view and say terminal and it's going to
open a terminal window inside Visual
Studio code in our current folder here
which is a bit convenient and we will
type python
main.py and if we wait we're going to
see a window pop-up and this is
confirming that our installation of both
Python and Pi side 6 is working and we
are ready to start learning about cute
for Python and this is really cool this
is really all I had to share in this
lecture and again the goal was to set up
a development environment we can use to
do what we do in this course here we
have Python 3 installed we have Pi side
6 installed and we installed the editor
that we will be using throughout this
course here don't worry about QT
designer at this point because we're
going to need it later in the course and
when we get to need it we will install
it and you're going to see how cool all
this is we are going to stop here in
this lecture and I will see you in the
next one
in this lecture we are going to try and
understand what is actually going on
here in the last lecture we blindly
typed in the code to make sure the
environment is working but now is the
time to try and get an idea of what is
going on here
before we do that we are going to go to
where we saved our code and we'll copy
the code from the last lecture and
rename this zero to understanding the
code I think that's going to work better
and it's zero two not zero one so my
body here and I am going to drag and
drop this on top of Visual Studio code
to open that project
if I hit on main.py here you see the
exact same thing we saw in the last
lecture we have syntax highlighting now
and the first thing I want you to do
that is going to save you a little bit
of time is to come to file and the
toggle or to save okay you're going to
click on auto save here and now things
are going to be Auto saved as you type
things and you won't have to hit Ctrl s
or come here to say save that's going to
save you a bit of time now let's try to
understand the code but before we do
let's make sure it actually runs so we
can come to view terminal and hit the
app arrow and this is going to bring
back the command we typed the last time
we run a visual studio code this is
really cool if you want it
you could uh type this python
main.py and hit enter and uh python
let's type that correctly
and if we run we're going to see our
window pop-up here now the code here the
first line is importing the components
that we need for this code for this
project we need Q application and Q
widget and these are part of the cute
widgets module that comes as part of the
pi side installation that we did so this
is really important the components we
need
and here you could either import CIS or
not import it but I just wanted you to
see that it is possible if you want to
process command line arguments okay so
since is a module that is responsible
for processing command line arguments
and once you have them they are going to
be picked up by the queue application
instance you have here and you will be
able to process them in your QT
application so that's what the system
here does okay once we have our assist
thing here we can create our application
and an application is really like a
wrapper that is going to be in globing
everything you do in your QT application
so it is going to be the thing
responsible for running your application
and waiting for things to happen as you
interact with your application for
example if you click on a button all
those things are going to be happening
under a wrapper that is this app object
here this is as simply as I can explain
it after we have our application we will
create our widget and we name it window
in our application here and by default
Widgets or Windows in qt are hidden so
we need to show show it and after we
show it we will call the exec method on
our application to start the event Loop
and the event Loop already is a while
loop something that keeps looping around
waiting for things to happen so for
example if we run our application let's
bring back our terminal and we run it
again
so for example if we run it and it
happens to be a button in our
application here if you click on the
button the event Loop is going to be the
thing that catches that click you do on
the button and it is going to respond I
realize I am jumping around here trying
to go as deep as I can but that's the
gist of what is happening here the exact
call here is going to start the event
Loop so let's say that here okay and
this is really all that is happening
here another thing I want to say is that
if you have been working with python you
may have seen things like this calling
the exact method with an underscore
after the C and let's try to run the
code with this so let's bring back our
terminal and try to run again and you're
going to see that it is going to work
but you see a comment saying that this
thing will be removed in a future
versions of python and they are
recommend demanding using exec instead
and this is coming because of older
versions of python that had problems
with the exact command here in Python 3
I believe this is going to work well so
the convention we will be using here is
not to use the underscore we will be
typing exactly like this and you will
see the same things on the print
function you have in Python so if you
wanted to print something you can say
print and it is going to print that but
you can also use an underscore again
this is something that comes from older
versions of python but in this course we
won't be using these underscores here
another thing I want to point out is
that you can use the documentation to
learn about everything you want about Pi
side 6. so for example if you want to
learn about this widget thing we are
using here you can go to your favorite
search engine and say Pi site sets and
say kill with it and this is going to
pull the documentation for acute for
python if you open this you will have
all the information about that thing
so let's see what they say here you can
click on more
and you can increase the size of this
because I like larger text and it is the
atom of the user interface it is a base
widget on top of which you can build a
lot of other things I do recommend
reading up on this if this is your first
time with QT so you can create a widget
a widget can have a bunch of components
you can create other widgets on top of
this but we will have a chance to learn
about all these things as we progress in
the course but it won't hurt to take a
moment and read about this and how you
can use this in your python applications
so this is all I had to share in this
lecture trying to shade some more light
on what is going on behind the scenes we
are going to stop here in this lecture
and the next one we will try and
organize our code in separate files so
that things are easier to work with I
will see you in the next lecture in this
lecture we are going to organize the
code in classes to make things a bit
easier to work with in the last lecture
we did something like this even if we
didn't use cumin window but the code
looks strikingly similar and here we
will be using everything in the global
scope so we will be doing things in a
single file you see we are importing
this here to be able to process command
line arguments we are creating a window
and this is a different kind of window
that can have menus toolbars and things
like this and we will have a chance to
learn about this later you're going to
see how it looks in a minute another
special thing about this kind of widget
or window is that we can give it a
central widget and that's what we want
to do here to be able to use buttons so
we have the window here we are going to
give it a title using the set window
title method and after that we will set
up a button which is meant to leave
inside this window here a button is
something you can click on you can give
it the text and once you have your
windows set up again we have the window
let's try to draw this here we have a
big window inside the big window we will
have a button and this button is going
to have text here press me and this
button is going to be within this window
because of the setting we are doing here
that's how these things work after we
have the window we will show it and we
will start our event Loop and the
application is going to work now someone
would argue that putting all the logic
for these buttons and things in the same
file is really bad and we need to
organize this the first level of
organization we're going to do is to
extract the logic for the window in its
own class and we do that using the code
you see here so we will create a class
in Python the class is going to be named
button holder as you see right here and
it's going to be inheriting from Humane
window we will give it a Constructor and
if you know python object-oriented
programming this is not new to you so we
will have a Constructor and in the
Constructor we will be doing the things
we were doing in our main python file
you see we are setting up the window
title we are setting up the button and
we are telling the button to beat the
central widget for this button holder
class once we have this class setup we
will create an object of it in our main
python file again we have the
application object we created a window
notice what kind of window it is it is
button holder and this is going to
create an instance of the class that we
just set up on top here once we have the
window we're going to show it and kick
off the event Loop and this is going to
extract the logic of setting up the
window and doing all kinds of crazy
things in this class here someone would
argue that this is still not
maintainable it is bad we see the logic
for the buttons and the windows in our
main python file well we can do even
better and create a version 3 of our
application in which we are going to
extract the button in a separate file so
we can do something like this we can
create a file and name it
buttonholder.py and inside that file we
will put in the code to create our
buttons and windows and all kinds of
crazy things now in the main file what
we are going to do is to import the
things we need to use we will Import
Sales import application import button
holder and after that we will be able to
use button holder even if the details of
this battle holder class are not in this
file here and our main adopt py file is
going to be a bit easier to look at and
this is the main goal of this lecture
here making it easier to organize or
code in classes to make it easier to
work with now that we know this we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with us a little more okay here
we are in Visual Studio code and here is
the code we will be using here
organizing code in classes if you go in
you're going to see that it is a folder
with the main python file so we're going
to be starting from there let's drag it
and drop it on top of Visual Studio code
or to open it and if you look it is the
same thing we had in the last lecture
let's clean all this up and we will put
in the code for this lecture here we
will go on top and put in version one of
our code and to save on time I am just
going to paste in the code here and take
a moment to explain it because typing it
would really waste our time I will type
when I see that it is going to add value
but for now we just want the code here
in our editor so we are importing the
things we need we need queue application
Q main window and Q push button and now
that you see these new classes that you
don't know about it is a good time to go
to the search engine and try to learn as
much as you can about them so we can go
to
our search engineer and say Q main
window okay Q main window
and if we go and click here and again I
do recommend reading as much as you can
about this this is a main window that
provides a framework for building and
applications user interface and one
thing that is special about this class
is that it allows you to set up things
like menu bars toolbars dock widgets
status bars and things like this and it
is a really cool thing to have in your
application if you need these kinds of
things so we are going to be using a
basic version of this but I don't
recommend reading as much as you can
about this so let's come back to our
editor so we have a main window object
we are creating that is going to allow
us to set up menu bars status bars and
all kinds of crazy things we are going
to give it a window title and down below
we are creating a button Q push button
and again this is a good time to come to
your search engine and look for a q push
button so let's do that okay come here
you should really drill this Habit in
your workflow because it's going to
allow you to learn more things than I
could even tell you in a course like
this so the push button or command
button is perhaps the most commonly used
widget in any graphical user interface
so you can click on it and things are
going to happen and this is really how
it works this is how you create it and
you can connect slots to it and you can
do all kinds of crazy things with this
button component here for now we are
just interested in making it show up in
our user interface because it is easier
to work with after we have the button we
will tell our main window to use the
button as it's Central widget once we
have the window we will show it and we
will kick off the event Loop by calling
the exact method here this is all we are
doing now that we have this remember
this is going to auto save because of
the setting we did here you see autosave
is toggled on we can show our terminal
okay and we can hit up to bring back our
Command and let's make sure it is
highlighted so everybody can see it this
is the command we have right here python
main.py if we hit enter with this this
is going to show a window and if we
resize just a little bad I want you to
notice some of the things we did we have
our window title on top here okay you
can see it right here and we set it up
using this line here and we have a
button in the middle of the window right
here this is our button and it is saying
press me you can see the text here and
it is the text we set up here and I
really want you to make sure you
understand the relationship between the
code you type and the things you see
when you get to run your application
because this is going to give you a firm
understanding of how Pi side is working
to give you the user interface you are
seeing here now we have the application
here but some of you might argue that it
is really not well organized to save the
list to have the window and button logic
in our main python file and we will try
to improve on this what we are going to
do is to comment out our version one
here and I am going to put in a pair
year of block comments in Python this is
how you do it in Python you have three
double quotes and three double quotes
and in the middle you're going to put in
your code and that's going to be
commented down and I can copy what I
want to comment down
okay so let's put my code in here and
leave the comment on top this is a one
line comment in Python this is how you
do it and we will do version two and in
version two we will be creating a
separate class but the class is going to
still be living inside our main python
file here to do things in steps we can
go down and do our Imports these are the
same things we have been doing for a
long time we will go down and set up our
class
class battle holder and it is going to
be inheriting the Q main window we will
set up our Constructor
and it is going to be calling the parent
Constructor
and it is going to be calling the super
Constructor or the its parent
Constructor
now this class is going to be inheriting
from Human window so it is also going to
be some kind of human window in other
words it is going to have access to
methods we have in Q main window what
that means is that we can say something
like self set window title and we will
be we will be stealing this method from
cumin window and being able to use that
in our button holder class this is
classic inheritance in object oriented
programming so I don't need to say much
about this so let's put in our text
after that we will set up our button
because we have q push button imported
here so let's say button
equals Q push button press me
and the next thing we need to do is to
set up the button as our Central widget
again we have access to descent Central
widget method because this is a main
window it is inheriting from Human
window again that's what you should
understand here so we're going to say
self set Central widget and we will pass
our Button as the central widget
okay now that we have this we can go
down and do the usual thing we did on
top for example we can even copy from
what we did before okay so we can create
our application objects we're going to
go all the way to the bottom
we're going to create our application we
want to create a main window now we are
going to be creating a button holder so
what we can do is go on top and say
button holder so we will have our button
holder here and we will take out the
line to set the central widget because
we are doing that in our button holder
now that we have this I think we are
ready to start running this thing again
we have our class which is going to be
wrapping around the logic to show the
window and put in the fence inside the
window and we are doing all this in the
Constructor of our button holder class
this is really cool let's bring up our
terminal window and make sure we can run
this
and if we run this huh what is the
problem here I think it is the self-tent
we are passing here so let's try to run
again
and now you see that we see the same
thing we saw before but now we have
extracted the logic for a button holder
and setting up the window and putting
things inside the window in its own
class and this is really cool now again
we can do better than this by moving
this button holder class in its own
separate class or its own separate file
I should say let's do that we are going
to comment out this let's put in our
blog comment section and we are going to
move everything we don't want in here
from this section into our comment and
what we will do is to create
a new file let's copy the code for the
button holder class here and I'm going
to copy that let's go to the left and
create a new file call it button
holder
Dot py and inside this file we are going
to paste in our class again nothing
special here we don't need the queue
application here because your
application is used in our main python
file but we need the Q main window and Q
push button we don't need this imported
here okay now what we need to do is to
just copy the part that instantiates the
button holder fan okay we can do that
and for this to work we need to import Q
application so let's do that we can copy
the line that does this here and says
think we need CC I think we also need
the sales imported let's do that and now
we need to also import the battle holder
class we are going to say from button
holder import
button holder and this is going to give
us access to these things and you see
that all the Dirty Work to set up the
main window and put fence inside the
window is moved in our button holder
file and this is really cool this is
what I wanted you to see and we will be
doing things this way going forward in
the course to make our organization a
bit easier let's show our terminal
window and run to make sure everything
still works I think we still have
something running here let's run let's
say python Main
and if we do that this is going to run
and we see our thing here and our code
is organized in classes and this
achieves what we set out to do in this
lecture here in this lecture we are
going to learn about signals and slots
in queued and the signals and Slots are
a mechanism that QT provides to connect
things in other words when something
happens we want to respond in some other
part of our code suppose on the left
here we have a push button and we want
to do something when that button is
clicked the way we do that we set up a
piece of code that is going to respond
to the right here
and when the button is clicked QT is
going to emit the signal this signal is
going to be picked up by whoever might
be interested in this button being
clicked and they are going to respond
the mechanism QT provides allows us to
connect signals to slots and when you
have made this connection when somebody
clicks on the button the method that is
responsible for responding is going to
respond and do whatever it is you do in
the body of that method suppose we are
operating a message whenever you click
on the button we are going to print a
message whenever you click on the button
we are going to print a message
and QT provides a simple syntax to allow
us to do that let's look at that here I
have a piece of code and what I am
setting up here is a simple button
you can see that right here and we want
to respond when this button is clicked
we say that we want to respond in this
piece of syntax you see here so we say
button the name of the variable we say
that and then we say the signal that we
want to respond to in this case the
Signal's name happens to be clicked and
once we do this we are going to call the
connect method on this
and when we say connect we are going to
specify the method that is going to
respond to this button being clipped
Within These parenthesis here in this
case it happens to be button collect if
you look on top here we have this method
we are defining it and in the body of
this method we are just saying a message
you clicked on the button so this is
what we are doing here we are connecting
a slot or a method that is going to
respond when this button is clicked and
this is what does this connection here
so some of you must be asking Daniel how
did you know that we have this clicked
signal on our button and this is another
instance of where you need to use the
documentation so we are interested in
the Q push button component we want to
see which kind of signals this component
emits let's go to our search engine
pretty fast
so let's close all of this here and we
are going to say Q push button or QT for
a python and if we do that we will have
the documentation for a q push button if
you click on more it is going to tell
you everything about this component but
what we really want is to see the
signals that this component emits and if
you go down in here we see synopsis
functions virtual functions slots so
this is a slot you can activate if you
want to do something like this but we
don't see any signal from this component
and this is because all of these signals
are coming from a parrot class of this
push button component
and that happens to be what you see here
this little thing called the two
abstract button the documentation for
cute for python is not really good for
example we can't scroll around to see
the things that are cropped off but we
are lucky in this instance we can see Q
abstract button if you click on this
this is going to open the documentation
for Q abstract button if you click on
more it's going to tell you what this
does it is going to implement an
abstract button and all kinds of buttons
we have in qt are going to be inheriting
from this button here but again what we
are interested then are the signals that
might be emitted by this component again
we see functions if we scroll down we're
going to see virtual functions if we go
down we're going to see slots we can
activate if we go down we're going to
see signals and this is what we are
interested in so the Q push button
component can emit a signal to let us
know that it is clicked it can emit to
let us know it is pressed it is released
it is toggled and we can do all kinds of
crazy things we can even grab these
arguments or these parameters and use
them to do things in our QT for python
applications so let's go back to our
slides now that you know where I got to
the information that we have
this clicked signal so we have connected
to it and then after we do this
connection and start the application
when we click on the button we're going
to see the message from our method here
and this is going to be really cool so
we are just responding when we click on
the button and we know the syntax we use
to do that and this is really cool we
can go even further and grab the
parameter that is emitted by the signal
for example if you go back to our
documentation in the browser you're
going to see that the clicked signal can
emit a parameter to let us know whether
the button is checked or not we're going
to take advantage of this and show you
how to handle parameters and signals we
can go back to the slides and what we
are doing here after we set up the
button we're going to make it checkable
and this is going to make it toggle its
state whenever we click on it so if we
click on it first it's going to be
checked if we click on it again it's
going to be unchecked and it is really
going to be simulating the behaviors we
have with check boxes if you click on
the checkbox it's going to be checked
you click on it again it's going to be
unchecked and it is basically going to
be titling between these two states
that's what we are simulating here with
our Q push button component but we are
doing this because we know when it emits
the clicked signal it can also give us
information whether it is checked or not
and we are going to be printing that
state in this print statement here so we
are just going to say print
and we are going to print the data
parameter that we get in this function
here and we are just doing the usual
connection we did before notice we are
saying button clicked connect and we are
activating the button clicked method
whenever this button is clicked and that
method happens to be on top here so this
is something we can do we can respond
when something happens and grab the data
that was sent to us by the signal and
use that in our method and this is
really cool
let's look at another example before we
head over to visual studio code and play
with us here we are going to use a
slider so we will set up a slider
component and again this is something we
have in QT this is going to be something
like this where you have a slider that
you can slide around to increase or
decrease values we are going to give it
a minimum a maximum and a value and
whenever we move the slider the slider
is going to emit signals that its value
is changing and because I checked the
documentation I know that the slider has
a value changed signal let's go to the
documentation and really show you this
you should be able to find things out on
your own in the documentation let's say
Q slider
and if we open this up in another tab
we are going to see all about this
component you can read about this here
but we are interested in signals that it
might Emit and we don't see
okay if we go down here
we're going to say that this slider is
going to inherit a comprehensive set of
signals and among these signals we have
a value changed okay if we click on this
we are going to see that this signal is
going to pass a value to us and we can
grab this value and do things with it in
our QT for python applications so this
is what we are doing in the slides here
we are grabbing that value okay and
printing that out in our print statement
here and all this is happening because
of the connection we did here so
whenever the value changes we want to
call this method to respond to the
slider moving and we will grab the
current value from the slider and do
things with that now that you know all
this and again I realize it is a lot of
information but we're going to go
through the step by step in Visual
Studio code and I hope you are going to
understand so let's go there and play
with this okay here we are in a visual
studio code we have an empty folder in
which we will be doing our thing let's
grab and drag on top of Visual Studio
code to open this and we will create our
main python file main.py and this is
going to give us our starting point the
first thing we are going to do is to put
in version one of our application here
and again I am not going to type all
this we are just importing the
components we need we are setting up a
method that is going to respond when the
button is clicked we are setting up our
application object the button
and we are doing the most important
thing here let's take out the line and
do the connection ourselves so we are
saying button whenever the button is
clicked and you see that we don't have
autocomplete here so we have to auto
complete the signal and then connect
that's what we do and we want to specify
the thing that is going to respond when
this button is clicked so that's going
to be button clicked here
now we have the connection made and we
are just going to show the button here
notice that all we have in our
application here is a simple button so
this is what we are going to see when we
run this application here let's bring up
our terminal window
and we will simply run this just like we
did other applications and when we do
that we see a little window pop up that
is saying oppressed me so this is our
button inside this window here and if we
click on it you see it's going to print
the message and it is doing that because
of the connection we did here let's
close this and comment out this
connection to show you that if we don't
make the connection we won't see this
message when we click on the button
because there is no connection between
this button whatsoever to this slot here
or this method if I can say it like that
let's run it again
to see this going on we have the button
and if I click on it a thousand times
I'm not going to see a single message
here unless I come back in my code and
activate the connection and run the
application again then we will see the
button and if we click on it we're going
to see things happening as a response to
the connection that we did here this is
really the syntax again how do I know we
had this clicked signal I use the
documentation let's go down and show you
that you can also handle parameters or
arguments coming in your signals let's
comment this up so we have this done
here and we will put in version two of
our code let's go down and uncomment
this
let's take out my blog comment here and
again notice that we have a parameter in
our slot here and we don't have any
mention of that parameter because the
clicked signal is going to send it
anyway it is our decision to decide
whether we handle it or not that's what
we are doing here so we have the
parameter and we're going to be printing
the checked State and to be able to
toggle between the checked and not check
the state you have to enable that on
your button component and that's what we
are doing here setting checkable to True
once you have this you can run the
application and you are going to see
that as you click on the button it is
going to be constantly toggling between
the chat and unchecked Stage let's run
this we can go to view
and a terminal and run this again but
before we do I think we need to kill the
application that was running earlier so
let's clear and bring up our application
if we click press me it is going to
check it is going to say checked true we
click again checked false we click again
checked true this is happening because
a behavior that is built into this
battle component is that if you click on
it while you have this property set to
true it is going to be constantly
toggling between a checked and unchecked
that's what we can do here and again the
real intent in this example is to show
you that you can handle parameters that
come in your slots and at the syntax you
use to connect doesn't really change you
decide whether you handle them or not by
putting the parameter here if you put
the parameter in here you can handle it
in your application depending on the
data inside this data parameter if you
decide not to handle it you can just
take this out and you're going to fall
back to what we had in our previous
example
so let's run again so we can show our
terminal and kill the application that
was running
and I started again now if you click
you're going to see that we are just
going to see the message but we don't
see the state because we're not handling
our parameter here if we put it back in
and say data
okay and run again I think we can run
again now we are going to see the
checked State because we are handling
that in our slot here I hope this makes
sense and I did the best I could to put
in a bunch of understandable comments so
that you can really understand what is
going on here let's comment this out and
give you another example using a slider
because that's a bit more interesting
so let's put our code in the comment
block here and we can go down a bit long
and put in our code and again we are
just going to be importing the
components we need
okay notice that we are importing the QT
named space if I can say it like that we
have our slot which is going to be
handling some data but the slot is going
to be responding to a slider being
removed and again we talked about this
in the slides we have our slider we want
it to be horizontal if you want you can
make it vertical but it's not going to
be beautiful we have the minimum set
again I know about these methods because
I am familiar with QT for a lot of years
but if you are just getting started your
best bet is use the documentation to
read about all these things for example
again if you go back to slider I think
we have that somewhere here
you can see the methods that it has okay
so we have a maximum method to get the
maximum we have a method to set the
maximum you can read about all these
methods to see things you can do with
your UI components in your QT for python
applications and again after we have the
slider we are connecting to the value
change signal and we want our method to
be activated whenever the value changes
and whenever the value changes we are
going to grab the current value which is
sent to us
as part of this signal and we will be
printing that right here
if this is not making too much sense
maybe we can run the application so
let's go to terminal
and run it
and this is going to give us a slider
here
okay and if we move it you're going to
see things happening here again you see
that it was starting at 25 if we move it
up it's going to go to 27 28 29 it's
going to go all the way to the maximum
which is 100 or we can bring it all the
way to the bottom which is one okay and
we can move things around you can use
this component in your application and
it is going to work really well but
again in the meat of this lecture here
is to let you know how to make
connections between signals and slots
and I hope you know how to do this right
now this is really all I had to share in
this lecture I hope you found it useful
we are going to stop here in this one
and I will see you in the next lecture I
would like to welcome you in this new
chapter where we are going to be
exploring cute Wizards and widgets are
really the basic components you use to
build your user interfaces and in QT
these are going to be coming from the
cute widgets module we will have a
chance to look at Q push button q line
edit and all these widgets you see here
and they will allow you to build cool
user interfaces without waiting anymore
let's head over to the next lecture and
get started in this lecture we are
exploring the Q widget component we have
in the QT framework and this is a
fundamental component in built-in user
interfaces in that it is going to give
you a base window on top of which you
can do all other things so for example
if we set up a q widget component and
show it we will have a pair window and
on top of this window we can really
build any kind of structure to have all
kinds of crazy user interfaces we might
wish for in our QT applications and to
use this it's really simple now you have
the fundamentals of how you do things in
q24 Python here I am going to show you a
simple example and this is a class that
is going to be living in its own file
the class name is Rock widget it is
going to be inherited from Q widget and
Q widget is really the base class that
we can use in our QT applications it is
going to have a Constructor and in the
Constructor we're going to be doing our
basic work here another thing I am going
to show you in this lecture is how we
can use layout to lay things out nicely
this is really not the place to
introduce layouts but we really need
them to have the flexibility to lay
things out flexibly inside our widget so
that's why I am doing that here you also
see that we are having a bunch of
components we have a bunch of buttons we
are doing connections to slots
and we want to respond when these
buttons are clicked and in our code we
will also set up these methods that are
going to respond once we have the widget
we are going to display it in our main
python file and here you see that we are
doing the usual we are importing the
file that contains our Rock widget class
and we are setting up a widget which is
an instance of our Rock widget component
we are showing it and kicking off the
event Loop to have our application show
up now that you know these things we are
going to head over to visual studio code
and play with us step by step okay here
we are in our Visual Studio code editor
I have an empty folder which is going to
be containing the source code for our
example here let's drag it and drop it
on top of Visual Studio code to open it
and I can create my main python file and
in here we can do the usual we can
import the things we need we can also
import sys set up our application object
and we are going to say window equals Q
widget we are going to show the window
and we are going to say up exact okay to
start our application here notice that
we say it's the windows here and we
don't have q widget imported and we can
import that here Q widget it is part of
the widgets module in pi side 6 and if
we do this and run the application we
should see a widget pop-up let's show
our terminal so that we can run the
application easily and we can go up
until we find the command to run this
and you see this is going to pop up our
widget nothing special here what we are
going to do is to move the logic to set
up the widget inside a separate class
and have that widget as a base on top of
which we can build other things so let's
do that we are going to create another
file we are going to call it Rock widget
and in that file we are going to import
Q widget from PI side Q2 Edge yet so
let's do Q widget and we'll set up our
class the class is going to be named The
Rock widget it is going to be inherited
from Q widget and it is going to have a
Constructor so let's make sure we put
that in and for example we can give it a
window title let's say self set window
title and we are going to call this rock
widget and now that we have this notice
that we did just the minimum we needed
to have this be a valid python class
here so we can come back to main.py and
import we're going to say from from Rock
widget import Rock widget and we want to
create a q widget component this time we
will create a rock widget you can do
something like this now that we have
this we can run let's see if this
actually works and if we run we should
see the same thing we saw before but now
this is not an instance of Q widget it
is an instance of rock widget which
itself inherits from the Q widget class
now that we have this we can start doing
all kinds of crazy things on top of this
curated component what can we do for
example we can set up a bunch of buttons
let's do that we will also import Q push
button okay we already know Q push
button let's say button one equals Q
push button and say button one you can
do this
if I can type what are we going to see
when we run this application let's try
to run it we are instantiating an object
of rock widget in main.py remember and
we want to see where this button is
going to show up in our user interface
that's a question you might have let's
try to run and if we do this you see
that we don't see our button but we set
it up in our code the reason this is
happening is that this widget doesn't
know where to put the button and to put
things inside our widgets or our window
we need to use layout and the layout is
a way let's try to draw this so that it
is really easy to understand now we have
our widget component and we put our
button in our code here to attempt to
put some kind of button in our user
interface but this widget component
doesn't know how to lay them out there
is a way in QT you can tell a widget to
lay things out either vertically okay
something like this or horizontally from
left to right and you do that using
layout let's start with a horizontal
layout to start out we have a class
which is called qh box layout and it is
a way we have to lay things out
horizontally in our class and to do that
you set up a an object of that class we
are going to say layout or button layout
okay we can do something like this and
it is going to be a qh box layout
component okay once we have the layout
we can add events to this layout so
let's say button layout add the widget
and you see we have a bunch of methods
you can add other layouts inside this
layout you can add the trial to widget
but in this case we are just interested
in adding the widget which is going to
be our button one so please make sure
you really understand the flow of things
here we have our parent widget and we
want to put things inside this widget
using this layout here once we have our
widget in the layout now we can call the
set layout method on the widget to let
it use this layout component to lay
things out inside the widget component
here so we're going to say self set
layout and we are going to say button
layout we can do this now if we run we
should see our button inside our widget
and if we do this you see that we have
button one here and this is really cool
now that we have this infrastructure in
place we can add other buttons so for
example we can go down and copy this I
think we can do that Ctrl alt down this
is going to copy this in Visual Studio
code and we can name this two button too
okay and we can add a widget again Ctrl
alt down this is going to copy the line
and we can say button 2 here and now we
can go down and try to run we should
have two buttons button one and button
two and you can keep going putting in as
many buttons as you want another thing I
want you to see is that you can lay
things out even vertically so we can
change this to be a vertical layout
let's do that QV box layout and we can
change this to be a QV box layout this
is all we need to do and because this is
a vertical layout now when we add these
buttons here they are going to be added
in vertical order let's try to run
button one should be on top button two
should be below let's run again
and we have this here and this is really
cool now you can see that we can use
this widget and this is really the idea
I was trying to convey here as a base on
top of which we can build as a complex
user interfaces and we will be doing a
lot of that in the course here right now
we are just laying the foundation so
that you really understand what is going
on under the hood now that we have these
buttons we can really do all kinds of
crazy things for example we can set up a
bunch of slots that are going to be
activated whenever we click on these
buttons now you already know how to do
this lens but now we are going to be
putting in these methods as part of this
class they are going to be methods of
this class here so for example you can
say def button one and when it is
correct we are going to print a message
saying button one clicked okay we can do
something like this we can even copy
this method code I think we can do that
okay so let's do that and do that for
button tool clicked and we are going to
say button two collect and we can
connect signals to these slots that we
are setting up here the way you do that
you come down say button one you already
know this if it is clicked okay we want
to connect to a signal to a slot that's
going to be self button one clicked we
have this for button one we can
duplicate this button too so we can
select the line shift alt down this is
going to copy the line in Visual Studio
code that's why I love Visual Studio
code and we can put the code here to
duplicate it and we are going to say
button 2 click now we have the
connection from this buttons to the
slots we have down here if you click on
button one you should see this message
if you click on button two you should
see this message let's view terminal
and we are going to try and run again
but we have the previous application
instance running so we can kill it and
run again and if it runs Watch What
Happens below here
okay so let's click on button one button
one clicked
what is going on here ah the problem is
that we are setting these methods up as
methods of the class but we're not
telling these methods that they belong
to this class here you do that by
passing in the self argument sorry for
that so let's do self and I think at
this moment this should work let's clear
and run again and if we click on button
one it's going to say button one clicked
if we click on button two it is going to
say button to clicked if you wanted you
could change this to be laid out
horizontally by using q h box layout
that is going to lay out thanks
horizontally if you run again they are
going to be laid out horizontally if you
click button one clicked if you click
button to clicked this is really all I
wanted you to see in this lecture again
if you don't know what qh box layout and
the QV box layout to do I invite you to
use the documentation let's do that QV
box layout and you are going to have a
lot of information about these things
you can really read this if this is your
first time you are going to pick up a
lot of information and this is going to
be very helpful in your career as a QT
for a python developer we are going to
stop here in this lecture and I will see
you in the next one
in this lecture we are going to explore
the Q main window class this is a class
that allows us to work with things like
menus toolbars status bars actions and
it is really cool what this is going to
give us is a window like this but a
window that has little parts or
components that we can customize for
example in many applications at least
graphical user interface applications we
have something like a toolbar or a menu
bar on top and below that we might have
a toolbar that contains things we can
click on to make things happen after
that we are going to have something like
a main or a central widget and in that
widget we are going to put in the main
component of our application if it is an
editor or a text processing application
users will be able to type things in
this component and things like that we
might even have a storage bar or
something we can use to show some
messages or whatever you can design your
applications reusing this components
that are built into the Q main window
class that you can instantiate in your
QT applications so this is what we are
going to do here we will create a class
that is going to be building on top of Q
main window and on top of that we will
be doing our own things and you're going
to see that we will have the ability to
add menu bars toolbars status bars and
that's going to be really cool once we
have this class inherited we can add
menus like we see here so we can call
the menu bar function on Humane window
and this is going to give us a menu bar
object that we can manipulate once we
have it we can add other menus for
example you see here we are adding a
file menu and the add menu method is
going to give us a menu object that we
can use to manipulate our menu here for
example we can add actions to our menu
and we are doing that right here and
this is going to give us an action we
can manipulate later here in our QT
applications I realize this is a bit
convoluted but actions are a thing that
you can use to manipulate a user doing
something in your application suppose we
have a quick action like this and we
want the user to be able to trigger this
either from the menu bar or the toolbar
so the user could go in a file menu and
select quit or they can go on the
toolbar directly and click quit the way
QT does this it adds in an intermediary
step through which you can go to trigger
this action and this is what this action
is an action is an object that you can
either add to the toolbar or the menu
bar and when the user tries to quit
either through the menu or the toolbar
all these things are going to go through
the same action and you can connect this
action to a method that is going to do
things in your QT application and you
don't have to duplicate your code either
in the menu bar or in the toolbar I am
going to show you this when we hit
Visual Studio code if it is not making
sense yet but this is a really good
design when it comes to the QT framework
so we have the action here and this is
the action that we will be connecting
slots to for example you can see
whenever this action is triggered this
is a signal that is emitted by Q action
you can go in the documentation to take
to check this out when this actually is
triggered we will call a method called
quit and this is going to quit our
application as you are about to see
again the meat of this here is to show
you how you can manipulate menus in your
QT applications once you have the menu
bars you can add menus to that menu bar
and once you add the menu you will have
a menu object you can add actions to we
are repeating the same process here we
are adding an edit menu and in this edit
menu we will add actions to copy cut
paste and do and do and we will be
seeing these things in our user
interface and if we really want it we
could grab these actions and connect
slots to them to do things in our
application and I think we will even do
an application like this later in the
chapter here so stay tuned for that down
here you see that we have a bunch of
other menus we have Windows settings
help we can do this next another thing
we can do is also manipulate the toolbar
and you do that by setting up a toolbar
object like you do here once you have
the toolbar you're going to add that to
the main window using this method here
and you can add actions to the toolbar
you see we are adding an action we are
adding an action and before we add the
action we're going to create it so this
is how you create your action you can
put in a bunch of things and you can
connect slots to the action this is
really what we are doing here another
thing I want you to see is that you can
even pass an icon when you create the
action and this icon is going to show up
wherever ever you add that action in
your user interface and this is really
cool down here we are adding a separator
in our toolbar and we are even adding a
push button in our toolbar you can do
that if you want it is possible let's
see how you can also use storage bars to
use this notice bar you set the status
bar on your main window using the
setting we have here and we are creating
a status bar object in place and passing
that in down below you see that we are
doing a button that is going to be
showing up as our Central widget and
once we showed this we are going to see
the entire application here and this is
really cool down here we have our
methods that are going to respond
whether we click on buttons or things in
the toolbar all the menu bars and you
see the method here you also see the
method to quit and once you have
distance your application is going to
work now that you have this we can head
over to visual studio code and play with
us step by step okay here we are in our
Visual Studio code editor we have an
empty folder that we are going to be
using to do whatever we do in this
lecture here let's drag and drop this on
top of Visual Studio code and we will
create our main.py file on top of this
we will also create a main window file
let's do that and this is going to be
where we create our main window class
the first thing we want to do is to make
sure we have the correct Imports so we
are including queue application and Q
main window we will need to pass an
application object to this window to be
able to quit you're going to see how we
wire these things up but for now just
put Q application here let's go down and
set up our class it is going to be
nothing really special the class is
going to be called main window it's
going to be inheriting from Q main
window let's make sure you can see that
it is going to be inheriting from cumin
window here we are doing our Constructor
then and we have a member which is
called app which is going to be the
application instance that created this
main window here and we will be using
this application member to quit the
application again you will see how we
use these things in a minute now we have
a main window object I think we can go
in the main py file and try to use this
so let's go down and put that in here it
is not going to be anything special we
have q application imported we are
importing main window from our main
window file the class we just set up
here and we are creating the window
which is main window we are showing it
and we are kicking off the event Loop
nothing special here so let's show the
terminal window to be able to run this
and we are going to say Python
main.py and if we do this we will see a
window pop-up here but you may think
this is a normal widget to Daniel why
all the fuss around two main window let
me show you we are going to go back to
main window here and we are going to put
in a piece of code like this okay so
this is going to be setting up our menu
bar so we will call the menu bar method
on our main window object and it is
going to give us a menu bar that we can
use to add menus to our main window
object here and again how do I know this
the documentation let's go back to our
browser and we can say Q main window
here Q main window and if we look here
we can see a method called menu bar you
can see that right here and they are
going to say whatever this method does
it is going to return the menu bar for
the main window this function creates
and returns an empty menu bar if the
menu bar does not exist so we are going
to create it and we can go through these
menu bars to add menus to our main
window this is really cool right so we
are calling add menu to our menu bar
object again we can go to the
documentation and see what we get from
this guy this is going to return the Q
menu bar okay and uh this is why I don't
like the documentation for cute for
python there should be a link for a q
mini bar you can click on to go there
but we have to go back and search here
so let's do Q menu bar and we can open
this in our browser once you see this
you're going to see that we can do a lot
of things and one of these is add a menu
and this is what we are using in our
application here to add a menu called
the file on our menu here let's run and
see our menu live let's clear
properly and run python main.py if we do
that look at what we have here we have a
menu we can click on it to do things but
it doesn't have anything inside yet but
we're going to fix this in a minute
let's close the application first but
what we can say for example is file menu
okay file menu add action and we are
going to say something like quit if we
do this and run and come back to our
window here if we click on file you see
we have a credit we can add menu options
in our menus and this is really cool
okay another thing we can do is actually
grab this action and use it to respond
whenever the user triggers this action
for example you can say quit action okay
we can name this quit action and we can
connect to it and make a slot respond
whenever this action here is triggered
and this is really cool so let's go down
and Define a quit method so let's go
down here and say def quit app for
example and it's a method so we need to
pass a self here and down below we are
going to say app quit and can we quit
we're going to say quet autocomplete is
not helping here but I think this is
going to work so let's go with this and
once we have the action we can connect
this slot to it so we can say create
action trigger connect and we will
connect the self method that is called
quit app let's see what happens if we do
this and this is really cool if it's
going to work let's clear and run the
application now we have our file menu
and if we hit quit the application is
going to go away let's try it again file
quit it is going to go away and this is
really cool we can add a bunch of other
menus now that you know how to work with
ADD menu and add actions on menus so to
populate this I am going to add an edit
menu and let's take out these unprisoned
symbols because we don't want to go into
that here they have some use in QT but
we're not going to go into that here now
we have another menu added to our menu
bar and we are going through this menu
to add a copycat paste and do redo menu
options and we will see them in our user
interface if we run the application
let's go to view terminal and a clear
and run our application if we do that we
have an edit menu this is really cool if
we click on it copy cut paste and do
redo and this is really cool you can do
this things using the Q main window
class in cute for python let's add a
bunch of other menus to make this a
little bit interesting we have window
we have settings we have help and let's
add a comment here if we run let's see
if we can see these things showing up on
our user interface and we see our thing
here and this is really cool now I hope
you know how to work with menus and many
options and you even know how to respond
when one of your many options is
triggered now let's focus on toolbars
the first thing we do is to create a
toolbar object and a set a few
properties on that
and before we create the toolbar we need
to import the toolbar and the queue size
class here we are using to give it the
icon size the size object here is coming
from cute core so let's put that n and
if you want to know how I knew that how
did I know that queue size is coming
from cute core well you have to use the
documentation and if we go back to our
browser
I really want you to be familiar with
using the documentation because it is an
invaluable skill queue size for acute
for python or Pi side 6. and if we look
for it they should tell us where this
thing lives
cue size you see it lives in the cuticle
module that's how I know this lens
because I don't memorize them so we have
this imported I think we can import Q
toolbar from cute widgets because that's
the module where it lives we don't even
need the Q application imported here
because we don't need this so let's take
this out I think this is going to work
and we can go down and keep working on
our toolbar here once we have the
toolbar we can add in a bunch of actions
so to start let's say toolbar add action
and add in our reduction how about that
we can add the quit action to the
toolbar and you do that by saying
toolbar add action and let's say quit
action because I think we have it on top
create action where is our quit action I
think we have it right here we can copy
it and put that down below here I think
this is going to work let's see what
happens if we run this application this
is going to be really interesting and
this is going to explain why we have two
actions in QT so let's see our toolbar
you can see our action right here here
and if we go in file you are also going
to see that we have a quick thing set up
here but we are managing what happens
when a user triggers this action in one
place whenever this action is triggered
we are going to call the quit app but we
can trigger this action from different
places in our application and we can
either do that from the menu or from the
toolbar if we create from the menu the
application is going to die if we quit
from the toolbar the application is
going to die and we have one single
method to respond to all those possible
sources of this action being triggered
and I really hope this makes sense so
let's go down and keep playing with our
toolbar here another thing we can do is
create our own action just like we do
here action one Q action we are giving
it some information and apparent because
its Constructor requires this
information again I know this because I
read the documentation so go in the
documentation read the information for Q
action and you will know why we need to
do things like we do here now we need to
import a few action Q action leaves in
the cute GUI module so we will import
that like we do here and if we go down
our application should be happy now that
we have the action we can pass a lot of
information for example we can pass a
status tip and this is something that is
going to pop up when you hover over your
action we can do something like this you
can respond when this action is
triggered and this is going to be a
method we set up in our application and
after we have the action ready we can
add it in our toolbar just like we added
our quit action on top here and this is
really cool before we run let's go down
and actually set up this method so let's
copy and say that
and we will pass self as a parameter we
will go in the body of the method and we
can print a message saying action one
trigger okay can do something like this
now that we have this let's make sure it
is the same name we are using here
option one triggered yeah or we can use
it or we can even say action triggered
this is going to do let's run the
application okay we have some action
added to our toolbar if we click on it
we're going to see that our action is
triggered so you can respond to things
happening in your toolbar and this is
really cool we can even set up another
action but before we do let's go to the
place where our source code is and we
will add in an image because we want to
pass an icon to our action here and make
it show up in our user interface you can
download the source code and have access
to this short image here okay so you can
use this let's go back to our code and
we can go down and set up another action
this action is going to be taking up an
icon and I think icon is coming from the
cute GUI module so let's say Q icon I
think we have that imported here here so
we can do this and if we set up this
then we can pass our start PNG icon it
is in our project we just pasted this in
here and we can pass the icon on top of
the other pieces of information that we
passed earlier so we have some text that
we pass in our action we have a parent
we can pass the status tip message here
and we can respond when this thing is
clicked and again this is going to
activate our slot here that we set up we
can make this thing checkable and to be
honest I don't remember what this does
but we're going to figure this out when
we run this and we are going to add this
to our toolbar let's try to run this and
see what the checkable thing does
okay so we can run this and we have our
theme showing up here we see this thing
is triggered and the checkable thing
is not helping out in this moment I
think we can comment it out and see what
happens this is how you learn about
distance okay so let's recite this and
if you click you see this thing is
triggered I think the checkerboard then
here is working in the same way as we
saw for a push button so we're not going
to be talking about this anymore here if
you want to see the signals that are
sent by a q action again we can go to
the documentation and look for queue
action
let's do that Q action in cute for
python you can read all you can about
this class if we go down hopefully we're
going to see the signals that it emits
you see it has a triggered signal and it
can pass a parameter which may be useful
if you have set the checkable state here
I think that's the use for that so you
have this now you can read the
documentation on Q action and know all
you can do with it now I think we know
how to work with toolbars let's see how
we can work with the status bar and the
starters bar is this little section
below your window I think we should show
this it is this little thing Below in
which you can show a bunch of messages
and we're going to show how this works
in a minute so let's go back to the code
but before we go to status bars I just
remembered something I didn't show you
we can add a separator to separate
lengths in our toolbar and we can even
add a widget something like button in
the toolbar and this is really cool if
this is helpful for whatever you are
building with QT for python please take
advantage of that let's import Q push
button for that to work so Q push button
and let's go down and make sure we have
no more squiggles so we have the thing
here let's run and see what this gives
us and you can see that you can even add
a button okay if you look closely you're
going to see that we have a separator
here so you can separate things in your
toolbars now let's go and work on status
bars and all you have to do to work with
the status bar is to set a status bar
object to your main window so we use the
set throttle support method here and we
will create the object in place and set
that as our own status bar status bar is
in the cute widgets module so let's add
that here kill status bar and once we
have it we can start showing things in
the status bar what we are going to do
is to set a message to the status bar so
let's go in our slot so let's go in our
slot that responds when the toolbar
button is clicked so we're going to say
Self Storage bar and we are going to say
show message this is a method you can
use to show a piece of message and you
can pass the message so message from my
app let's say that and you need to
specify a timeout you can specify you
can leave this empty let's first see
what happens if you leave this empty so
let's do that if you click it's going to
say message from my app and you can see
that if you click on this the message in
the status bar is going to change and
another thing that is wiredate QT is
that if you hover over something that
has a tooltip message that tooltip is
going to show up in the status bar
that's what you see here but if you
click you see that my message is going
to show up and it is not going to go
away it's going to stay there as long as
you are hovering over the thing you can
pass the timeout parameter here so let's
say we want to wait for this for three
seconds three thousand milliseconds this
is what we mean here so we can run the
application again if we run it and click
on our thing the message is going to
show up but it should go away in three
seconds and it does go away so click one
two three and it is going to go away
after three seconds and these are the
things you can really do with your Q
main window class we saw that we could
use it to play with menus and menu bars
we played with toolbars and we later
played with service bars another thing
you can do with our application to make
it a little less boring is to put some
button in the middle as the central
widget and we are setting up the button
here and we are going to set up a method
that is going to respond when this thing
is clicked when the button is clicked
here so let's make sure this is aligned
properly and we wanted to respond when
it is clear effect so let's put our
method here we are going to define a
method let's say Def and we are going to
give it a name and we want to go inside
and put some message out clicked
on the button you can do something like
this and this is going to be our Central
widget and we want to mark this as a
method and if we show the terminal and
run we're sure to see a button
in the middle of our application and if
you click on it you're going to see the
message here and this is really all I
wanted you to see in this lecture I
apologize it turned out to be really
long but Q main window is really
interesting now you know how to add
menus to your application you know how
to work with the toolbar and you know
how to add status bar messages to your
application the toolbar is very flexible
I think you can even move it so you see
you can move it around in your
application you can play with us it is
really cool we are going to stop here in
this lecture and I will see you in the
next one
in this video we will learn about the Q
message box class and this is a class
that allows us to set up transient
temporary message Windows like this you
can see something like this it has a
title it has a message inside and we
have two buttons one to accept and one
to reject and it can really be any kind
of message and Q message box allows us
to set up something like this in QT
there are different ways to do this and
we will start by looking at the hard way
to do this and here is a simple function
that is going to do this we will set up
a q message box object and through a
bunch of method calls we will apply a
bunch of properties to our message box
object so we can give it a title we can
give it the message to show we can
really do all kinds of crazy things but
one other good thing I want you to
notice is that you can control the type
of message box this is going to be by
changing icon here so you can make it a
critical message box you can make it a
warning message box you're going to see
what all these things mean here another
thing you can do is specify the buttons
that are going to show up on your
message box so in this case we want to
see an okay and cancel button but it is
also possible to put in other buttons if
you want to you can just keep ordering
those types of button in these
parentheses and they will show up we
will also set to the default button so
the OK button is going to be on by
default or it's going to be highlighted
if I can say it like that once we have
the message box object set up we will
show it and we show it by calling the
exact method this is going to make it
pop up on the screen and we will grab
whether the user pressed OK or cancel
through this return variable so if the
value of this is Q message box okay we
will know that the user chose okay if it
is something else we will note that the
user has chosen cancel and if you pop up
this message box you will see all this
kind of information here I know this may
be cryptic if this is the first time you
work with something like this but I will
show you how this works in a minute when
we hit Visual Studio code so this is the
hard way to do things QT provides a
bunch of static methods you can call on
Q message box to show different kinds of
message boxes and it's really simple to
trigger all you have to do is say cue
message box critical this is going to
give you a critical message box you can
pass in the parent you can pass in the
title the message and the kinds of
buttons this vent is going to show okay
once this thing shows up and the user
chooses either of these buttons you will
know through this return variable that
we are setting up here and we will do
the usual check we do to know whether
the user pressed OK or cancel so this is
one kind we can also have information
message boxes and and you can really see
that what is changing here is the method
you call if you call the information
method you will get an information
message box if you call the critical
method you will get a critical message
box and we can keep going on really
going through them all we have a warning
one we have an about message box and
here you see how you can trigger those
message boxes what we will do is set up
a bunch of buttons in our user interface
and whenever you click on one of these
buttons we're going to trigger a
different kind of message box so this
one is going to trigger the message box
we set up the hard way the second one
here is going to trigger a critical
message box and we will keep going until
we hear to the about message box as you
see down here and here is how our
buttons are going to look so nothing
complicated here but one thing you
should notice is that we are using a
vertical layout to lay these guys out
how you see them here so we're going to
do this in a minute when we hit the
visual studio code so let's head over to
the editor and actually do this so here
we are in our editor Visual Studio code
we will set up a new project and we will
be working in this folder called message
box you can see that it is an empty
folder we can drag it and drop it on top
of Visual Studio code to open it here
and we will create our main profile and
we need a widget file that is going to
be containing our widget we will set up
our widget class like we do any other
widget so we will import the components
we need and we will set up a widget
class here once we have this we can head
over in our main dot py file and put in
the code that is going to trigger that
widget I think at this point we can
actually run to see that our application
actually works and then we can start
building other things we need let's
clear and say python main pi and if we
do this we should see a window pop-up
here and we will build our user
interface on top of this the first thing
I'm going to do in our widget class is
initialize the buttons that we will be
using in our Constructor so let's do
something like this and I am going to
just put them in and we will be looking
at the meaning of this as we go through
the lecture here so we are setting up a
window title for the widget here and we
want to set up a bunch of buttons we
have a hard button that is going to
trigger the message box we set up the
hard way we have a critical button a
question button an information button a
warning button and an about button and
each of these buttons is going to be
triggering a different kind of message
box to kind of learn about all these
things here once we have the buttons if
we run the application remember we're
not going to see them because we need to
tell this widget class how it's going to
be laying out all these buttons here but
let's try and show you what is going to
happen if you try to run the application
at this point if you do it's really not
going to work but here it is just
complaining about the slots that we
don't have in place but the point is
that this is not going to show the
buttons the way we wanted them shown so
we needed to use a bunch of layouts here
and you can see that I imported a v box
layout because I have a purpose for this
okay so let's go down and set up our
layout you already know about layouts
here we will set up a vertical layout
and once we have the layout we will be
adding all these buttons to the layout
then we will set the layout to the
current widget here this is how we are
doing this let's say that we are setting
up the layouts here and let's see if we
try to run we are probably going to get
a problem because we don't have the
methods n but we can set up all these
methods here so what I am going to do is
copy this and go all the way to the
bottom so this is a Constructor we can
go down below and set up the method and
I am going to duplicate this
one two three four five times so let's
do one two three four five okay and this
is going to be critical let's do that
okay the second one is going to be
critical the third one is going to be
questioning I am doing this live so that
you guys don't have a problem with what
I am doing here so let's do this
together question information let's do
this so let's go down and do information
we're going to paste this in and this is
going to say information and we're going
to go to the
warning button
so this is the slot we need to set up
after information
let's do this warning
and we need to go to the last one which
is going to be about
okay so let's deal about
and this is going to say about
and let's try to fix our
indentation here because python is very
serious about this
so we need to use one tab space after
the line of the functional definition
here let's go to view and show terminal
and if we do this
and run again
this should run now and it is going to
show our buttons we have done the signal
slot connections after the definition of
each button so at this point if we click
on hard we should see hard if we click
on critical we should see critical if we
click on question we should see question
and let's make sure that everything is
working here and about is about now we
need to show a bunch of message boxes
and we will start by the hard way here
so let's take out the text we have in
our function
or method and I will go on top and say
that we are doing things the hard way
here and I am going to put in my
function definition what this is going
to do it's going to create a message box
object and you can check this class out
in the documentation you already know
how to do that but let's do it together
anyway so let's say Pi side 6 Q message
box this is going to open the page for
this class in the QT documentation and
you can click on more to read on what
this class does this is going to display
a primary text to alert the user to a
situation and you can really read all
you want about this this is how it looks
on the Mac this is how you set it up and
it is what we are basically doing in our
example here okay let's come back to our
code we will set up the message box
object we will give it a size we wanted
to have a minimum size of 700 and width
and 200 in height this is the meaning
here you can give it a window title we
can give it the text to show we can give
it some informative text we can give it
an icon we're going to make it a
critical message box
and we can give it the buttons that it
is going to show and after this we will
specify the default button and the
critical thing here
is to show the message box
okay and you do that by calling the
exact method on this once you call the
exact method the method box is going to
show up and when the user clicks on
either of the buttons we will know which
button the user clicked on through the
return value here so if the user clicks
on OK we will get a number representing
the OK button if they click on cancel we
will get a number representing the
cancel button this is how these things
work now that we have this I think we
can run and see it in action we're going
to show our terminal window
and we will run
okay we are going to click on the hard
button and if we do that we're going to
see something pop up here so we have a
message box here and if we click back on
our code let's make sure you see what
all these things mean you see the title
we set up is showing up here okay you
see the informative text is showing up
here and the message we set up is
showing up here and you see the buttons
we set up to try and play with us you
can play you can click on cancel it is
going to say user choose cancel if you
click on OK you can see that we know
which button the user clicked up on but
you can even play with this for example
let's take out the cancel button in our
standard buttons here
so let's check this out and if we run
let's run again okay and click on hard
we're going to see that we only have the
OK button okay so and this is really
cool now you know that you can use these
standard buttons to control which
buttons show up in your message boxes
and this is one way to set up a message
box if you want you can do it this way
but QT provides a rather easier way to
do this because all the work here is
really repetitive it is just setting up
these messages the title The text the
informative text and really the
differentiating factor is the kind of
Icon you apply to the message box let's
change this to warning for example to
show you that you can do this so we can
change the icon to change the kind of
message box this is going to show let's
try to run again so we can run and if we
hit this is going to show a different
icon let's cancel out of this and change
this back to what it was was let's hit
Ctrl C to go back there it was a
critical one let's try again
and if we hit hard we're going to see
that we have a different icon so they
are different in which icons they show
the rest is really the same so because
of this reason QT provides a bunch of
easier to use static methods that you
can call directly to get this then show
up without doing all the repetitive work
here we will start by the critical one
because it is what we have here and I am
just going to put in the code all you
have to do to get this to work is to say
qmessagebox dot critical and called the
critical method on the Q message box
class and then you pass in the parent to
the title the message you want to show
and the buttons you want the message box
to have this is really all you have to
do the rest is the same we will check
which button the user clicked through
the return value of the critical method
here and if it is equal to the number
that represents Q message box okay we
will know that they also chose okay if
it is another value we will note that
the user didn't choose OK and they chose
cancel because we only have two buttons
here or they just closed the message box
so that's another option too let's run
and make sure we see what is happening
here we will click on the critical
button we can show our terminal and run
again and if we click on critical you
see that we have a really good message
box here again you can see the title we
set on top here you can see the message
and you can see our buttons here let's
go down and try the other ones if we
choose cancel you see that it is cancel
if we choose OK you see that it is okay
down here and this is working exactly as
we want the rest is really the same all
we are going to be changing is the kind
of method we call so we can go down and
do the question one let's put some space
in here and put in the code for the
question message box and we are calling
the question method the value is going
to be captured in the return value and
we will check which button the user
chose here let's run and see this
running so we can show this question
asking the question we can click Ok
We're going to know if we click OK we
can click on cancel on question and we
will note that we have chosen cancel I
am just going to go down and put in the
rest of the methods then I am going to
show you this running so that you have a
full working example on these guys here
okay so let's go down and put in the
information one so we call the
information method we can go down and
put in the warning one let's do that and
we can go down and put in the about
message box here all these are things
you can do I think it is better to also
document this let's say about here we
can go on top here and say warning we
can go on top here and say information
and on top here we will say question and
we will go to the top and say critical
and here the hard way was critical as
well
okay we have the thing and now if we run
all these buttons should work let's
bring up our terminal window
we can clear so that we have a clean
slate here if we run we should see our
tank show up if we click on hard we will
say message box we click on critical we
see a message box we click on question
we see a message box we click on
information we have an information
message box and be careful to look at
the different icons that show up because
that's really the main differentiating
factor we have a warning one and if we
click on about we will have some method
here and we can click OK and really run
this so the last one doesn't really need
to capture the return value because it's
just going to give the user a message so
the user can just close the thing that's
why we are seeing a cancel even if we
click on OK because the okay we click on
is not meant to give us a return value
that's how this link works so this is
really all a habit to share in this
lecture again if you want to learn more
about Q message box you are welcome to
read the documentation here you see the
documented the kinds of message boxes
you can look at but I think we have a
good starting point to work with us
throughout this lecture here I am going
to stop here and I will see you in the
next lecture
in this lecture we are going to look at
the Q push button class and you might
say haven't we used a lot of Q push
buttons enough by now well we're going
to look at it again because I want you
to see more on the signals you can
process in your QT applications on the Q
push button component here so you can
process the clicked signal you can
process the Pressed signal you can also
process the release decision depressed
and released signals are going to become
increasingly important if for example
you are doing a drawing application in
which you want to know if the user has
pressed it down and moving without
having pressed the release button so
that's why I want you to know about
these signals here and we will set up an
application like this so we will have a
button that says click we will connect
to these signals and we will be
processing these signals in these slots
that we set up below here and here in
the middle you see that we are setting
up a layout to have this button show up
better in the widget that we are
building here now that you know this we
can head over to visual studio code and
actually do this here we are in our
editor Visual Studio code we have an
empty folder in which we will be working
for this project here you can drag it
and drop it on top of Visual Studio code
when we do that we will create a main.py
file and we will create our widget file
once we have the widget file we will put
in our starter code we will import the
components we need and we will set up a
class that inherits Q widget nothing
special here we will also go into the
main file and put in our boilerplate
code if I can say it like that it is
going to create the application object
and we will create an instance of our
widget object here we will show it and
kick off the event Loop you already know
this let's go to the widget and set up
our button and connect to the signals
that we are interested in but before we
do that we can go to the documentation
and actually read a little bit about
these signals here so we can go to Q
message box now we want to look at Q
push button sorry for that let's go to Q
push button and if you remember we
didn't see the signals that this thing
has because most of these signals are
coming from the parent class of Q push
button and that happens to be the Q
abstract button class so we can click on
this thing here we will get to the
documentation and if we go down we will
see the slot but we are interested in
the signals and if you look here we have
the clicked signal we have used like a
gazillion times by now but we have the
Pressed signal and the released signal
that we are interested in playing with
in this lecture here another one you can
play with is the toggled signal that is
going to be triggered with after you
change the state of the button when you
have set the button to be checkable like
we have done in a bunch of previous
lectures but we won't be using this
signal here you can play with it if you
want let's go back to the code and
actually do what we want to do we will
come back to our widget class and put in
our Constructor code The Constructor is
going to set the window title it's going
to set up our button and we will be
connecting to different signals from
this button here and you can see that we
are trying to process the clicked signal
the Pressed signal and the released
signal and we're going to see how this
work to be able to see this in action we
need to implement these slots here so
let's do that so we can go down and
Implement these slots as methods of our
class and we have the clicked slot which
is going to be triggered when you click
on the button we have the Pressed slot
which is going to be triggered when we
press and down below we have the
released slot which is going to be
triggered whenever our button is
released here and we have all the code
we need now that we have this in place
we can show our terminal window
and we can clear and run the application
if we do we should see our button here
and once we see it we can press on it
you see we we see pressed once we go out
of the window of our widget we're going
to see that the system is going to think
that the button is released but if we
click again and release you see that we
have two signals when we release the
button we have the release signal but
one thing worth noting here is that the
clerk is both depressed and the released
signal so a click is going to be
triggered when you press and release but
if you want to do things only when you
press you can use the Pressed signal if
that is making any sense that's the
meaning of these signals here and I
really wanted you to be aware of this if
you really want to learn more about
these signals you can come to the
documentation and see what the official
QT guys are saying about this but this
is the gist of it this is really all I
had to share in this lecture I hope you
found it interesting we are going to
stop here in this one and I will see you
in the next one
in this lecture we are going to look at
the Q level and the q line edit
components in the QT framework and these
are components that allow us to set up a
component like this in which you can
type a single line of text so this is a
queue line edit and the label is
something you can use to set up some
level text something like the full name
you see here and if you need these kinds
of things in your QT application you
will be using Q level and queue line
edit the thing we have down here is also
a level and in the middle we have a
button that we will want to be using to
show the capabilities of q line edit
here to set these things up all you have
to do is to create these components
wherever you need them in your QT
application you can create a level just
like you do here you have a variable
label and you call the Constructor Q
level and you pass in whatever the label
text is going to be you create a line
edit component like this and we can do
all kinds of crazy things down here you
see that we are trying to connect to a
bunch of signals from the line edit and
we will be playing with this thing but
what I wanted to draw your attention on
is how we are going to lay things out to
make the user interface show up like
this and what we are going to do we will
first have an in globing vertical layout
okay that's what we're going to do then
we will take the full name level and the
line edit here and put them in a
horizontal layout so this horizontal
layout is going to show up somewhere
like here and then we will set up a
vertical layout which is going to be
this one and add these components to
that vertical layout so the vertical
layout is going to have the horizontal
layout added to add and after that we
will add the button and add the level
you see down here I want you to keep
this idea in mind because this confuses
a lot of people starting out with QT now
that we notice we can look at the
signals that we can play with for a q
line edit for example we can know when
the text in the line edit changes we can
know when the cursor position changes we
can know when the user finishes editing
and this mostly means the user hitting
enter we can know when return is pressed
which is also enter I don't know why QT
provides two signals for this maybe the
reason difference but I didn't care
enough to go investigate that we can
know when the selection is changed we
can know when the text is edited we can
do all kinds of crazy things
with these components end we will set up
the methods that are going to be
triggered by the signals and you have
all of them here we will play with them
in a minute when we hit Visual Studio
code but I do recommend pausing the
video and looking at each of them before
we go there so that you have an idea
about what we are about to do now that
we have this out of the way we are going
to head over to visual studio code and
play with us a little more here we are
in Visual Studio code we are going to be
working on this folder here which is
empty as you can see we can drag it and
drop it on top of Visual Studio code to
open it and this is going to open our
project in the folder let's create our
main python file and our widget file and
in the widget file we will create our
class like we always do make sure you
see the Imports we do here because we
will be using all these components we
can head over in the main file and put
in our code that is going to trigger the
widget showing up and and we can try
this to see if it actually works so
let's do that if we show it we're going
to have an empty widget and now we can
put in a bunch of line edits and labels
before we do let's go to the
documentation and read as much we can
about these guys you can look at Q level
if we open this in our browser this is
going to tell you what this component
does it is used for displaying text or
an image we will talk about images later
for now we are concerned with text and
if you go up you will see a bunch of
methods you can call on this to really
do all kinds of crazy things but this is
mostly used to show text in your QT user
interfaces we can also look at queue
line edit and pay Special Care on the
signals that this component has
so if we click on more we're going to
see it shows something like this in your
QT application you use it to type a
single line of text and you can do all
kinds of crazy things but for now we
will do the basics one thing I want you
to see is the signals that this thing
has because they are the most
interesting thing if you think about it
you use a line edit like this if you
want users to type text n and you may be
interested in different aspects of how
the user is putting in text for example
you may be interested in tracking the
cursor position you may be interested in
knowing when the user has finished
editing so that you can do something
with the text you can do all kinds of
crazy things and we will be playing with
a bunch of these signals if you see some
of that interest you I do recommend
clicking on them and seeing what they do
to really have an idea about these
things here and make sure you read this
detailed description to really know
about this component even more Ghana can
tell you in a course like this the
documentation is your weapon when it
comes to working with QT and QT happens
to have one of the best pieces of
documentation I have known in my career
as a software developer so let's come
back to our code and do what we need to
do the first thing we are going to do is
to put in our label and line edit
component
before we do that we will set up a
window title to make this
self-descriptive and we create a level
like this you can see that there is
nothing special about this and we have
our line added we have made our line
edit a member because of the soft
failure and we do that because we want
to be accessing this in Our member
variables if we don't make it a member
like this we want to be able to access
it in our methods I mean okay we have
this in place I think we will also need
another level which is going to show
something like this let me show you we
need another label that is going to show
the text here and we needed the button
so we can go down and put in our button
and make sure it is aligned properly and
we can even go down and put in our label
once we have these components the next
job is to lay them out we know that we
want the level and the line edits to
show up in a horizontal layout so we
will have the levels in something like
this then after that horizontally we
will have the line added so for this we
will be using a horizontal layout once
we have this horizontal layout we will
use an including vertical layout on
which we will be adding the button okay
so let me display it like this and at
the level
like this so this is the user interface
we want to set up and we will first set
up this horizontal layout here so let's
come down and set up our horizontal
layer it is going to be a qh box layout
we already know that and on this layout
we will be adding our label which is on
top here and the line edit once we have
this we will set up a vertical layout
which in turn is going to contain
everything in our user interface here
and we will apply the vertical layout on
the entire widget let's do this so we
can go down and put in our vertical
layout QV box layout and to be able to
do this you need to have imported all
these components here so we add our
horizontal layout to make it show up
first in our vertical layout so if this
is our vertical layout the first thing
is going to be the horizontal layout the
second thing is going to be the button
and the last thing is going to be the
text holder let people here once we have
the vertical layout we can apply it to
our widget and to do that you say self
set layout and we will be using V layout
here once we do this we should have our
user interface and the next thing will
be to play with our line edit component
here let's show the terminal window so
that we can run the application if we
run we should see our user interface
here let's make sure you can see it
because I just closed it by accident you
can resize it okay we have the full name
on the left because it is what we say in
our horizontal layout here we have the
line edit here we have the button and we
have our level here which we are going
to play with in a minute you can play
with the line edit and really type in
whatever you want you can say the sky is
blue my friend and you can really do all
kinds of crazy things one thing you
might be interested in when you have a
component like this is to grab the data
and we will be grabbing the data in our
line and edit and printing that to the
console when the user clicks on the grab
data button here so the first thing
we're going to do is come back to our
code and set up a method and the method
is going to be at this level so let's
make sure we take this to the correct
indentation in Python so this is going
to be triggered whenever the user clicks
on our button that says grab data and
what we are going to do we will grab the
text in the line edit notice that we are
saying self line edit and this is going
to be grabbing this component here the
line edit that we set up in our user
interface and we can call the text
method to grab whatever text is
currently in the line edit component so
all we need to do now is to do our
connection we can say button select net
self button required we already know
this must be becoming second nature here
let's run and see this in action we can
open the terminal we can run the
application it is already running I
think so let's close it
we're going to run it again to run the
new version of the application and we
can say this guy is blue if we grab data
we will see that the full name is the
sky is blue but we can put in something
like John snow and if we grab data it's
going to say full name it's Jon Snow you
can see that we can grab data in our
line edit component this is really cool
if you want it you can take this text
and actually apply it to the other line
edit we have down below here let's play
with this to really show you that you
can do that so we can close and we will
grab the name of the other line edit and
what is that text holder level
so we can do this okay we can copy it
and go in our method and we can say set
text on this guy and the text is going
to be what we get from the line edit
here so we can copy this and put that in
here this is something you can do you
can really play with this things and I
do encourage that let's make sure the
application is not running we can run
again have
and if we say Jon Snow in our line edit
and grab data we will see this print on
the terminal because we are printing
here but we will see that the text T now
are as the level here is also going to
change to John's now you can keep
playing with this let's say Daniel gray
and grab data it's going to say Daniel
gray and it is really working this is
one way you can use a line edit you can
grab the text in the line edit and use
it to do whatever it is you want to do
in your QT application let's play with
the other signals we have on our
component here for example we can
respond whenever the text in our line
edit changes let's go back to our line
edit which is down here let's put in
some space so that we can easily spot it
we are going to set up a connection we
are going to say whenever the text
changes in our line edit what we are
saying here we want to trigger the 10
text changed method and we can grab the
correct text and show it before we do
that to though let's go in our other
thing and comment out to the line that
prints the text because we are going to
be printing a lot of links we don't want
to be confused by this let's go and put
in the slot that is triggered whenever
the text changes so we can go down and
actually do that okay we have our text
changed slot and it is going to be
triggered whenever the text changes you
see we commented out to the print line
here we just want to see the changes in
our user interface this is okay let's
show the terminal and run and if we say
Daniel gray in here you see whenever we
type something we will be notified and
we will be responding in our slot here
and this is something you might be
interested in doing if you want you can
even uncomment the line that prints
something
and run again if you do that you will
see the changes both in the user
interface and on the terminal here
because that's where we are printing
with the print statement here this is
what the text changed signal does we can
comment out to the connection here
because we still have a lot to play with
so let's do that we might also be
interested in knowing when the cursor
position changes and we can set up a
connection like this to be notified and
we need to set up this slot that is
going to respond the slot right here the
cursor position method is going to have
two parameters one is going to be the
old position the other is going to be
the new position and how do I know this
well the documentation let's go back to
the documentation or queue line edit and
we can see cursor position changed you
can see that it has two arguments one is
the old position the other is going to
be the new
but the QT documentation didn't care
enough to name these things properly him
on uqt this is bad you should name these
things properly let's go back to our
code though so we will do better old new
we will know that this the old position
and this is the new position
and because of the connection we did
here we will have access to these guys
when this slot is triggered so we will
be printing this lens here let's make
sure we don't have anything else we
don't want to see printed we have the
Auto Connection commented out I think
this is going to do what we want let's
go up and run so we can run this and if
we do you see the crucial position
changing as we add events if we go back
you see the cursor position is also
changing this is really cool and at each
trigger of the method we have the old
position and the new position and this
is really cool this is something you can
do with this method here let's go up and
comment it out we might be interested in
knowing when the editing is finished
this is another signal we have on the
line edit component we will put in this
method here so we can go all the way to
the bottom and put in that method and
let me extra we remove spaces we don't
need and we have the connection and this
is going to be triggered whenever the
editing finishes and this is going to be
mostly when the user hits enter on the
line edit after typing in some text
let's show our terminal window and we
can go up and run and if we say DDD and
hit enter this is going to say that
editing is finished you see this is
triggered when you hit enter this is all
you can do with this signal here we also
have the return pressed signal let's put
in the connection for that and comment
out what we had before okay and this is
going to do the same thing as editing
finished again I don't know why QT
provides these two maybe they have a
difference but honestly I don't know
that difference yet let's put in this
method implementation that's going to be
return pressed we can go to the bottom
and put this in return press if we run
we should see that if we type DDD or
whatever you type in your line edit and
you hit enter you will know that return
is pressed and again it's when you hit
enter after you finish putting in some
text in your line editor another
interesting signal is one that lets you
know when the selection changes in your
line edit you might be interested in
this in your QT application so when the
user does something like this and
selects okay you will be notified of the
current selection and this is
interesting in some applications so we
have the connection and all we need to
do now is put in the implementation for
this method here so let's do that we can
go all the way to the bottom and put in
the method implementation selection
changed we have the connection whenever
the selection changes we call the
selected text method to know the
currently selected text and this may be
important in your QT application so
let's do that we can run this and
whenever we can type in something let's
say for example Jon Snow and if we
select John you see as we select more
things
the currently selected thing is going to
be shown here we just selected John if
we select to know we will see that in
our QT application here if we select the
entire thing even backwards I think
that's going to work you see we have Jon
Snow selected and this is really cool
this is something you can do in your QT
applications the last signal we are
going to process is text edited and as
the name says it is going to be
triggered whenever you have text changed
in your line edit and I think it also
provides two arguments showing the old
text and the new text to be sure you can
check the documentation for now I am
just going to put in the implementation
here let's go to the bottom looks like
it only gives the new text which is yeah
it's useful so we will be printing the
new text here which is going to be
passed to us in this signal here and
this is really cool let's try to run we
can clear
and run I think this is going to
conflict with other things now this is
going to do you see whenever we change
we have the new text show up and this is
really cool let's type in something
meaningful instead of this junk here so
we can say Jon Snow you can see that
whenever we change the text the changes
are going to be reflected in our
application here because of the
connection we did
and you can go on and play with more
signals I think I gave you enough
examples in this lecture here again the
goal was to be able to play with q line
edit and Q level Q level is going to be
used when you want to show a piece of
static text in your user interfaces
something like this you can use q line
edit when you want your user to type in
a line of text and this may come in
handy for example if you are setting up
a form to collect information from the
user the first name is the last name the
address the job they do whatever you can
collect all these things in your QT
applications and do things with them
this is all I had to share in this
lecture I hope you found it interesting
we are going to stop here in this one
and I will see you the next one in this
lecture we are going to look at the Q
text edit component and this is a
component that allows you
to type multiple lines of text in your
user interface or something like this
and I am sure you have seen this in a
lot of graphical user interface
applications so what we are going to do
is to set this up in a demo QT
application using pi side of course and
we will be able to type in the text get
the current text in this component like
we did for q line edit but we can do
much more for example we have the
capability to copy text to cut text to
paste text we can undo and redo
something you see in a lot of text
processing applications and this is
going to be really cool to set this up
it's nothing really special all you have
to do is to use the Q text edit
component you will set this up in a
widget that we will set up in a short
while when we hit Visual Studio code and
we will set up a bunch of buttons that
are going to allow us to manipulate
things in our text edit component one
thing I want you to see is that for
example to copy text from our text edit
component we are not going to go through
separate slot methods like we did before
what we will do is take advantage of the
fact that the text edit component itself
already has a slot that is going to copy
data so instead of delegating to a
custom slot that we set up in our own
application we will immediately call the
copy slot in our connection here and
this is something you might want to do
in your QT application apart from that
it is standard stuff we have been doing
all along and it's really not going to
be anything complicated now that you
know this we can head over to visual
studio code and play with us a little
more here we are in Visual Studio code
we have an empty folder that we will be
playing with in this lecture here let's
drag and drop it on top of Visual Studio
code we will close this and create
create our main Pi file Ty I mean let's
do that and we will create our widget
file like we always do
and in our widget we will put in our
starter code this is going to create a
starter widget which is empty and notice
the Imports we do here for the things we
will be needing here so it's quite a lot
make sure you put these things in once
we have this in we will head over to our
main file and put in the code that needs
to be there it's just going to be
creating an instance of our own widget
and showing it nothing special here we
can come back but before we do anything
it is my Habit to try and run the code
to make sure that I have no problems in
there so let's do that we should see an
empty widget pop-up and it does here now
what we are going to do is set up our
text edit component
together with a bunch of buttons that
will allow us to play with that the
first thing we do here we are putting in
a window title because this is a cute
text edit demo we set up our text edit
and if you go down for now you can
ignore the connections we are doing here
the first thing we are interested in is
laying things out so that we can see
them in our user interface we will talk
about all these connections later so we
have a copy button we have a cut button
we have a bunch of buttons all the way
to the clear button here now that we
have them we need to lay them out and
the way we want to do things we want all
these buttons to show up in a horizontal
layout that is going to be on top so
these are going to be our buttons and
below the buttons we will be putting our
text edit component if I can draw it
here so this other big thing below is a
text edit component so this is going to
be a horizontal layout and this is going
to be our text edit component and they
are going to be laid out in a vertical
layout so we will set up this horizontal
layout and add horizontal layout to the
vertical layout after the horizon Auto
layout decided we will be adding our
text edit component I hope this makes
sense so let's go down and put in our
layouts we can do something like this we
will set up our horizontal layout which
is going to be an instance of qh box
layout after that we will be adding our
buttons to copycat paste and do reduce
set plain text set HTML and clear after
that we will set up the vertical layout
which is going to be containing our
horizontal layout and the text edit and
notice that the text edit is set up as a
member because of the self plan here and
we are doing this because we will be
needing accessing this in a bunch of
slots that we will set up later the
let's take out this connection because I
think it might give us problems because
we don't have this slot in yet
and now that we have the vertical layout
we can go below and say itself set
layout and pass and this vertical layout
I think with this we will be able to run
our user interface and be able to see
our text edit component along with the
buttons that we set up here so let's
clear clear properly and run the
application and what is pro the problem
here set plain text we don't have these
guys yet I think we have a connection
that mentions that plain text let's
comment this out because we don't have
this n yet and we can try to run again
and if we do this is going to show up
and the meter of this lecture really is
to play with the Q text edit component
that we have down here
what you can do with it you can type
text you can say the sky is blue I am
and my city something like that you can
really do all you want you can put in a
lot of text and this is what you can do
with something like this and you can see
that using this as a business you can
really set up something like the Notepad
application you see in Windows here you
can do something like this you see it
does exactly the same thing now that you
know how to work with Q main window you
can set up a two main window object and
put in these files and menus and
whatever you can copy and edit you can
do all kinds of crazy things you can see
that now you even have the knowledge to
be able to set up a status bar you can
set up toolbars you can do all kinds of
crazy things so now that we have this in
place I think we need a way to play with
us so the first thing I am going to show
you is that we can copy the text in here
and paste it but I think the most basic
thing is to grab the text we have in our
text edit component but before we even
do that I forgot to tell you that you
should use the documentation to learn
about these fans so let's do q-text edit
here okay so we can come in here and
look at this and you can click on more
to go down and learn all you can about
this let's go to see the methods that
this thing has so we have a clear append
cut we have a bunch of signals we can
play with this on this and I think we
have a method called to play with text
we can use to get to the current text in
our text edit component here that's what
I was looking for so what do we do I
think we need to add another button
unfortunately so let's do that I think
it's going to be the first button so
we're going to say current text button
okay it's going to be a push button and
it's going to say current text so we can
put it in and we're going to connect
click connect
and we want to set up a method that says
current text button clicked so we will
go down and set up this method this is
the usual thing we do we can go all the
way to the bottom to the level of our
Constructor we will Define this method
it's going to be a member we can say a
print the current text so what do we do
we say self text edit
to plain text this is something that is
going to print the current text in our
text edit component here and this is
something we can do so let's run and see
this in action and we can see this and
if we say this guy is blue I love my
city we don't have the thing in the
layout so let's go back and add the
current Button as the first thing in our
horizontal layout we forgot that no
problem we can fix that add with it and
we're going to make this show up as the
first thing in our horizontal layout now
we can run if we do and type the sky is
blue and put in some other text here if
we get the current text you see that we
can see this so we are able to grab the
text in our component here now that we
can see this we can play with the copy
method or the copy slot if we go to the
documentation for a q text edit let's go
to the top again and look at the slots
that we have available on this component
we will see a coffee slot we can call it
and what it's going to do it's going to
copy any selected text to the clipboard
any selected text from the Q text edit
component here let's go down and play
with us
so we can open this up in our editor go
to the point where we declare the copy
button and what this is going to do it's
going to call the copy slot and this is
what I meant when I said we can avoid to
set up our own slot and immediately
forward the work to copy to the copy
slot of the text edit component we can
do it like we do here so this is going
to work right away we can run the
application and if you go down you see
that we can also catch because we are
forwarding The Cutting work to the cut
slot of the text edit component here
let's show our terminal and we can do
something like this and run now we can
say the sky is blue I think I don't need
to type my text all the time I think we
can copy from the QT documentation here
to have some text show up in our text
edit I mean we can paste here so once we
put in some text we can select something
and copy it okay how do I know it's
copied it's going to be leaving on my
clipboard I can even paste this in
another application so let's open
notepad and paste I am going to select
and paste you see that I am able to copy
from my QT application to another
application this is really cool so let's
cut because the cat feature is also
going to work because again it is
forwarding The Cutting work to the cut
slot of our text edit component if we
cut the text is going to go away if we
cut the text is going to go away if we
cut the tax is going to go away but we
can't paste yet why because our paste
button doesn't have a slot that can
immediately paste connected let's do
that to be able to really play with us
so we can say self text to edit paste
and this is going to forward the work to
the paste slot that we have available in
our text edit component again if you go
to the top you can you see that we have
a paste slot right here let's make sure
it is highlighted so everybody can see
it you can see it right here if you want
you can click on it and you can see all
about this slot here let's go back to
our application and clear and go up and
run again
we can still copy from the QT
documentation we can grab all this no
problem so let's come back to our
application and paste in and if we want
we can um okay we can copy the entire
thing here and we can go below here and
hit paste and you see that we can paste
text in here and this is really cool I
can't tell you how excited I was the
first time I could do this with QT but
it wasn't with pi side at the time it
was with C plus plus but the excitement
is the same
so we can copy cut and paste another
thing I want you to see is that if you
want you can set up your own paste slot
so for example we can say something like
this
okay we will be calling our own paste
slot and if we set it up we can copy
and go down and set it up can say Define
paste and it's going to be a method now
once we are in the body of this method
we can say self text edit and call the
paste slot ourselves because we can do
that this is something you can do and it
is going to behave exactly the same way
so let's do the paste button make sure
it is working it should be let's go up
and run
we can paste in the code
from what we have in the clipboard we
have something from our editor don't
want that so let's grab from the website
here and we can copy the entire thing
okay we click on the copy button here
and if we go down we can paste again we
can hit the paste button to paste if we
want we can even cut so we select
something we cut it out it's going to go
away we select something else we cut it
out it's going to go away and we can
keep pasting and really playing with
this to have as much fun as we can with
our application here another thing you
can do is undo and redo and I think
again these are forwarding the work to
undo to the slots in Q text edit if you
go to undo you see it here if you look
at redo you can see it here so I think
we can even undo if we hit and do this
is going to undo the operations we did
before if we redo this is going to be
redoing and you can do something like
this let's look at set plane text set
HTML we have the connections then but
they are disabled because we don't have
the correct slots implemented let's
Implement these slots here so we can go
all the way to the bottom and put these
M and let's take out the space here set
plane text is going to call the set
plain text method so this is the method
you can look up in the documentation and
we will just put in a bunch of text that
I stole from somewhere set HTML can say
it HTML formatted text to your plain
text edit component and you see I have a
few things with a few HTML headers we
have the BR tag we can set up a list and
you can see it right here this is basic
HTML if you happen to know something
about HTML let's show the terminal and
we will play with that a little bit and
we can run
okay if we do set plane text this is
going to put in the text if we say set
HTML you can see that our HTML is going
to show up here we have a header we have
an unordered list here and we have
something this is something you can do
in your application another thing you
can do with Q text edit is to clear the
text and you do that by calling the
clear slot that we have in our text edit
component if we go back to the
documentation again that's the best
source of information for you so let's
look at the slots that we have we have a
clear slot which is going to delete all
the text in the text edit let's go back
to our application and see that clear
the text goes away set plain text clear
the text goes away we can undo we can
redo we can do all kinds of crazy things
this is really all I had to share in
this lecture showing you how you can
play with Q text edit have as much fun
as you can with this component and then
we are going to stop here and I will see
you in the next lecture in this lecture
we are going to see another use for the
Q level component and that's using it to
show an image
what we want to end up with is something
like this we will have a level component
contained in our widget window and that
level is going to be displaying an image
let's look at how we can do this it's
really simple here we have our class
implementation we will set up an image
level that's going to be the name of the
variable it's going to be a q level
component and we will call the set Pixma
method.net and give it the image that it
is going to be displaying this image is
going to be living in our project under
the images folder and we will access it
and display it in all level once we have
the level we will add it in the layout
and apply the layout to our widget and
this is going to show the application
that we see here now that you know this
we're going to head over to visual
studio code and do this here we are in
our editor we are going to be working in
this folder here if you look in it is an
empty folder so let's drag and drop it
on top of Visual Studio your Cody here
and we will do the usual setup our main
dot python file we're going to set up
our widget file and in our widget file
we will set up our class which is going
to be inheriting from Q widget let's
make sure you see all the Imports that
we have here we're going to be needing a
lot of these and we can go in our main
file and put in our starter code which
is going to instantiate our widget
object and show it nothing special here
now that we have this we can try and run
it to make sure we have no problems so
let's do that clear and run this should
give us an empty widget and before we do
anything let's make sure that our image
is in the folder so what I am going to
do I am going to grab an image that I
have lying on my drive here I am going
to hop over in my project that contains
my main python file and paste in that
folder I am going to share this project
on GitHub so you can download this
project and grab this images folder and
use it inside you will find my image
here called Minions and it is a PNG file
now that we have this we can set up our
level component let's go back to the
widget file I mean we will set our
window title in and set up our label
component that's what we are doing here
after we have this we need to set a
pixmap to our level so let's go back to
the label documentation we can go back
there I really want you to see these
things in the documentation so let's do
Q level and if we go to the
documentation it should have a set Pixma
method set Pixma but we have that we
have a pixmap method which is going to
give us the pixmap which is really a
representation of the image that is
displayed in the level but I can't find
the set pixmap function not shown here
don't know why we have it as a slot so
we have set pixmap here and if we go in
okay we see set pics map this property
holds the level Peaks map setting the
Pixma clears any previous content and
you can see all the information here so
this is what we do with this you can
look at the qpix map class itself let's
go to the top they say what this class
does it provides a way to show an image
basically and all the information here
you can read if you want for now we are
going to come back to our project and
say Image level set Pixma and we will
build World a qpix map object in place
and you build it by giving it a path to
the image that it is going to be
displaying in our case the image leaves
in the images folder you can see here
and it is called minions.png let's do
that minion dot PNG and that's going to
be our offend now what we need to do is
to set up a layout so we can say layout
equals Q you can use any kind of layout
you want let's use QV box layout why not
we will add thanks to the layout so we
will be adding the widget that's going
to be our Image level and after we do
that we will set the layout to be
applied to our widget here set layout
this is the flow you have to drill in
your mind if you want to work with
layouts with them your QT widgets let's
pass in our layout here and I think we
have everything we need hopefully let's
show our terminal window what do we have
here the application is still running we
can kill it and clear and run again and
if we do look at what we see here we
have our minions image showing up this
is really how you use a level to display
an image and this is really all we set
out to do I hope you found this lecture
interesting we are going to stop here
and I will see you in the next one in
this lecture we are going to look at
cute size policies and stretches and
this is a concept we use to decide how
our widgets we have if the user
interface grows or shranks we will start
by talking about sites policies and a
science policy is a property you can
apply to your widget to decide how that
widget is going to behave if the user
interface grows or shrinks for example
if we resize the in globin window here
we have the option to let the level here
and the line edit grow at the same time
so the sound so the label is going to
grow and the line edit is going to grow
or we can choose to say the level is not
going to grow it's going to say to the
same width but the line edit is going to
grow and we can control these things
using size policies I know this concept
can be hard to grab but you are going to
see what this really means when we get
it to run this in Visual Studio code in
a minute another concept to that I
wanted to cover before we head over to
the editor is the concept of stretch and
the stretch is a property that says how
many units each widget is going to
occupy in a layout what do I mean here
if you look at our buttons.org in a
horizontal layout I set them up in a way
that the button that says one has twice
the width of two and three here and you
can set up by setting up a stretch so
what I really did I said the button
saying one here is going to have a
stretch of two the two bottle is going
to have a stretch of one the three
button is going to have a stretch of one
and at any point when the user interface
grows horizontally the button saying one
is going to be occupying twice the size
occupied by either of the other buttons
this is how you can say it using
stretches and you can use these Concepts
in your QT application if you happen to
need that
here is the code that is going to allow
us to do these things here for example
we have our level
okay and the line edit and we can set
the size policy you can say I want my
widget to expand horizontally or
vertically when the user interface that
includes my widget resizes and if you
want to expand horizontally you pass
that as the first parameter of the set
method here and if you want to expand
vertically you pass that as the second
parameter here in this case we are
saying we want to expand horizontally
for a design edit and we don't want to
expand vertically so vertically we're
going to be fixed this is how you say it
if you want to be expanded in both of
directions you can say it like we do
here and this is going to work down here
you see that we can do the same on the
level component you're going to see the
behavior of this when we hit the editor
in a minute down here we have the layout
the usual thing you already know
now we can look at switches and a
stretch again is specifying how many
units each component is going to be
using in the layout
in the example I showed I had an example
where the first veteran occupied twice
the space occupied by each other button
here so let's make sure I can at least
try to visualize this
so suppose the first button here has two
units okay it occupies two units and
each other one is going to be occupying
one unit you specify your stretch as the
second parameter to the add widget
method so we are saying that button one
is going to have a stretch of two button
two is going to have a stretch of one
and button three is going to have a
stretch of one and we can add these guys
to the layout to show them in our user
interface now that you know this we're
going to head over to visual studio code
and see this in action here we are in
our editor Visual Studio code we have an
empty folder that we will be using for
this project here we can drag it and
drop it on top of Visual Studio code
once we have this opened we can create
our files the main python file and at
the widget python file once we have the
widget python file we can put in our
starter code we have that right here and
we just set the window title this and we
can head over to the main python file
and put in our code which is going to
import the components we need we are
going to set up our widget and we are
going to show it
we can try to run this to make sure we
have no problems so let's show our
terminal here
and clear if I can type and we can show
the application we have our widget here
everything is working as expected the
first thing I am going to do is to set
up my components so that I have my full
user interface once we have it we will
play with size policies and stretches so
we have the level and the line edit we
will go down and set up the layout that
is going to be containing our line edit
and level
and this is nothing complicated so what
this is going to do is to set up a
horizontal layout
and it the horizontal layout is going to
be containing our level and our line
edit this is what we want to do here we
also want to set up another layout which
is going to be containing three buttons
and these are going to be laid out like
this this is the goal we have using
stretches so the first button is going
to be occupying twice the space occupied
by the other buttons let's go down and
put in the buttons let's put in the
buttons here I am going to paste them in
to save on some typing time here button
one button two button three and we will
add them to their own layout once we
have this we will set up a vertical
layout on which we will be adding these
layouts here to have them on separate
rows each one being horizontal if that
is making any sense okay we have our
vertical layout we can add in our
horizontal layouts and we set the layout
to the widget here okay now that we have
this I think we can actually take out
the second parameters for add widget
here because we will add them when we
want to play with stretches for now we
want to see our user interface and I
think we have it set up again if you are
confused we have our label component the
line edit we are laying them out
horizontally so the label is going to be
to the left the line editor is going to
be to the right after that we set up our
buttons one is going to say one two two
and three they are going to be saying
one two three here and we laid the
buttons in a horizontal layout as well
after that we will be setting up a
vertical layout which is going to be
containing those two layouts again to
the top we will be having our line edit
and our level so the level is going to
be to the left and the line edit is
going to be to the right down below we
will have our buttons so at this point
we don't have any stretch applied so
they will have the same size
as I can roughly draw here this is what
we intend to see when we run the
application let's go to view
and the terminal
and we can run again if we do we should
see our user interface and let's try to
play with it and see what is happening
here so if we resize the user interface
horizontally you see that the level
which is saying some text here is not
growing but the line edit on top is
occupying all the space
down below we can see that the buttons
are all growing horizontally at the same
rate and this is the default Behavior we
have for buttons in the layout let's try
to expand vertically and see what
happens you see the buttons don't expand
and the line edit and the level don't
expand vertically so let's try to use
size policies on the line edit to
simulate the behavior we have by default
so what we can do is go to the line edit
component here we can say line edit set
size policy because this is the method
that is going to be setting our size
policy and we can tell that Q science
policy horizontally I want to expand so
it's going to be expanding horizontally
we can say it like this but vertically
it's going to be fixed so let's do that
Q size policy fixed you can say that
here and this is going to be simulating
the default Behavior we just experienced
in a minute let's try to view and the
terminal and try to run if we do and we
try to expand horizontally you see
nothing changes because we are
simulating the defaults if we're trying
to expand it vertically we're going to
see that we're not going to expand
vertically but if we want we can set the
size policy fixed even horizontal let's
see what happens if we do that so we're
going to say fixed here if I can type
that and we are going to run the
application again now we have the
application and you see that if we
expand horizontally the line edit is
going to have a fixed size it's not
going to grow whatsoever and this is a
setting you might want to do if this
makes sense for whatever you are
designing your user interface for I am
going to turn this back to expanding but
another weird thing I want you to see is
that you can set your line edit to
expand even virtue so we're going to say
it's random here and if we try to run
again we will see that it will try to
occupy as much space as possible
vertically you can shrink it it's going
to go down but if we go up we're going
to see that it's going to be growing
vertically and it is still a line edit
even if it doesn't look like so so this
is where you shouldn't really do that I
am doing this to show you the effects of
size policies in your applications let's
turn this back to fixed you can also
apply size policies to the level for now
the label is not expanding either
horizontally or vertically but we can
play with us and really make it to do
weird things so let's shift alt down to
copy the line we're going to make this
apply something on the level and the
level is going to be expanding as well
horizontally because that's the setting
we have here let's see what happens and
we can run
and it is level with lowercase I think
that's the problem here let's run again
now it's going to run and you see that
the level now is occupying space all of
this space you see down here which is
gray is occupied by the level and it is
growing horizontally as well we can also
set it to grow vertically but we're not
going to do that you can play with it if
you want my intent here is to show you
how to use science policies to your
advantage and the main intent for size
policies is to Define how your widgets
are going to behave when the user
interface grows or shranks if the user
interface grows your widget may decide
to grow horizontally or vertically and
you can control these properties using
site's policies now that we have this
out of the way we can focus on stretches
stretches control how much space is
occupied by each widget in the user
interface for example if we run the
application again let's do that we see
that our buttons are occupying the same
space so you can say that each widget is
really occupying one unit of space
because they are all occupying the same
space to kind of simulate the default
Behavior we have we can specify a
stretch as a second parameter to the add
widget method as we saw but we will be
using a stretch of one okay so the unit
is going to be one and each of these
widgets is going to be occupying the
same space in the layout this is
something we can do let's scale the
application here
and run it again you're going to see
that it is going to be doing exactly the
same thing but now that we know about
stretches we can decide to choose one
widget and tell it to occupy however
many units we want so the unit is one
but we want the first widget to for
example occupy three units with this
setting button two is going to have one
unit button Loop 3 is going to have one
unit but button one is going to have
three units let's try and run we expect
button one to occupy three times the
space occupied by button 2 and button
three that's the setting we have here
and if our user interface grows you see
that that's going to be three times if
you measure this you're going to find
that out I think it is easier to see it
if we set button one to two so let's do
that
and as we grow now button one is
occupying two times the space occupied
by the other buttons here you can see
that right here this is really all I had
to share in this lecture showing you how
to play with size policies and stretches
use this if it makes sense in your QT
applications we will stop here in this
lecture and we'll see you in the next
one
in this lecture we are going to look at
the cube read layout component in your
QT applications and this is a component
that allows you to lay out widgets in a
grid and it's really likable so you have
a table here which has three rows and
three columns as you can see here and
the first thing here is going to have an
index of zero zero so it's going to be
at row 0 column zero this is going to be
at Row one column one that should be
this thing here if you target this
linear it should be at row two zero one
two and column two you use these kinds
of indexes to Target where you want your
widget to show up in the grid layout now
that you have the idea let's see what we
can achieve with this in this lecture we
will be setting up a user interface like
this this is going to be a grid but you
see that we have the ability to tell a
component to occupy more than one row or
more than one column and we do this with
a property called row span or column
span and we do that in code as you see
here so here is an example we have our
buttons we are setting them up button
one all the way to button seven we set
up a grid layout component and we
specify the location where the buttons
are going to leave for example button
one is going to be at 0 0 so the first
one is the row the other one is the
column button two is going to leave at 0
1 button 3 is going to leave at one zero
button 4 is going to leave at 1 1 and
all the way to button 7 which is going
to be leaving at 2-2 and you might be
asking what are these additional
parameters you pass when you set up
button two and button three well this is
because we want to set up a structure
like this so suppose we have three rows
and three columns let's try to do this
as evenly as I can and we want button
one to occupy slot zero zero that's
going to be this guy here zero zero zero
zero column that's the minion and we
have button 2 occupying zero one so this
is going to be button two button two is
way to occupy one row okay the
additional parameters are going to be
specified the row span and the column
span and this button is going to be
spanning one row and two columns so
button two is going to show up
throughout here okay this is what we
want to do for button three it is going
to be at index one zero so that's going
to be our three here
but it is going to take up two slots
vertically the rose band is two that's
what we see here and down below this
should be three two if we go to button
four it's going to take one one so one
one that's going to be our button four
and you can keep completing these things
as you see but the main idea is that
button 2 is going to occupy two columns
because we have two as the column span
and button three is going to occupy two
rows because we have a row span of two
hopefully this is making some sense and
if you go to the top you see that we are
setting up a size policy for button
three because we want it to expand in
all directions to occupy as much space
as possible and that's going to allow us
to have a user interface like this that
we are after now that you notice we can
head over to visual studio code and play
with us a little more okay here we are
in our editor the current project is
going to be living in this folder here
grid layout we can grab it and drop it
on the Visual Studio code editor and we
are going to create our files main.py as
usual and we want to do widget that P1
once we have this we will put in our
code for the widget usual stuff really
make sure you see the Imports we have
here
you can see them all but we will be
needing some of these and we can head
over to the main file and put in our
starter code make sure this runs so
let's bring up terminal and run this
and we should see an empty widget now
that we have this running we can come
back to our widget and actually set up
our buttons remember the user interface
we are after we have a bunch of buttons
so we have button one all the way to
button seven here they have names one
through seven and we are going to use
the grid layout to show them in this
widget here so let's go down and make
sure we set up our layout here it is
going to be a grid layout to be able to
use this you need to have imported Q
grid layout I don't think we need the
horizontal layout here we don't need the
vertical layout here if we need them we
will import them back but if you have
Imports you don't need you can take them
out here
so do we need to line edit we don't I
think let's remove that and we will need
the size policy in a minute okay now we
have the layout and one thing I want you
to see is that we specify the location
where the widget is going to show up in
our grid layout using indexes like this
so we have the row position and the
column position
after that you may also specify the rows
panel like we do for button 2 and button
three in this case button 2 is going to
take up one row and two columns button
three is going to take up two rows and
one column and that's going to give us
the user interface we want once we have
this we can set the layout to the
current weather layout and it's going to
be grid layout you can do that and I
think we can run the application and see
our user interface in action let's go to
view and terminal
and run
if we run we will have our user
interface you can see that button 2 is
taking up space
for
two columns okay and button three is
taking up space for two rows but we
can't see this because we didn't
instruct this button to expand in all
spaces as much as it wants so let's do
that we are going to go back to the code
and enable this line that sets the size
policy to expand in all directions once
we do that our button is going to expand
and fill as much space as it can and you
can see that it is working to our
advantage now this is really all I had
to share in this lecture showing you how
you can use grid layout use it if it
makes sense in your QT applications we
are going to stop here in this lecture
and I will see you in the next one in
this lecture we are going to look at the
Q checkbox and Q radio button components
in your QT applications and these are
things you use to let users choose
options in your applications for example
you may want your users to choose an
operating system that they like and you
may want to give them the option to
choose multiple choices so you can let
them for example choose windows and
Linux or either of these options another
option is to let them only choose one
and if you want to do that you may do
something like this using radio buttons
if they choose one the other is going to
be disabled and at any point they will
only be able to choose one thing so they
can either choose a b or c but they
can't have a and b enabled at the same
time and this is what we call an
exclusive button if you want you may
also set up a checkbox to be exclusive
and I will show you how to do this in a
minute but this is what we are after in
this lecture here we will build a user
interface like this using qradio button
and Q check box here is a simple example
of how you can set up non-exclusive
checkboxes in your application and the
main message I wanted to convey here is
that if you want to group a bunch of
check boxes you will put them in a group
box this is something very crucial to be
able to work with these components so we
will set up a group box for the
operating system that's what I'm in here
and we will set up our check boxes we
have a Windows checkbox we have a Linux
checkbox and we have a Mac checkbox and
we are doing some connections here to
know when the user toggles the checkbox
but for now let's worry about laying
these things out once we have the group
box we will set up a layout that is
going to be shown in our group box and
we will be adding these check boxes to
the layout this is a bit convoluted but
this is really what we have to work with
in QT so again we have a group box we
have our check boxes and we will be
adding the check boxes to the layout
that is going to be shown in our group
box so we will be adding the windows
Linux and Mac checkboxes to the layout
and after that we will be applying this
layout to our group box this is what we
do here and once we do this our group
box is going to be kind of wrapping
around our checkboxes and treating them
as a single unit you can move around if
you want to do that and we will see that
we can add this group box to other
layouts to really have a complex user
interface in our QT applications here
you see the slots that we will be using
to know when the user toggles our
checkboxes if they toggle the windows
checkbox this method is going to be
activated if they toggle the Linux one
we will activate this if they tackle the
Mach 1 will activate this nothing
special here
if we go down we will see that we can
also set up exclusive checkboxes and the
meat of this is to set up a button group
again that is going to be logically
grouping these buttons together and once
you have this button group you can say
that you want them to be exclusive by
calling to set exclusive and passing in
a true value and this is going to make
these buttons exclusive once you do this
you want to have the option to choose
multiple options again we may have
something like this for checkboxes and
once they are exclusive you can only
have one chat you can't have more than
one selected and that's the behavior you
have with the exclusivity here if you
wanted the default exclusive Behavior
you can use radio buttons and again they
work the same we can have our group box
here once we do that we set up our radio
buttons we will be adding the radio
buttons to a layout okay and we will be
applying this layout to the group box
that we have here using the line here
now that you know this I think we can
head over to visual studio code and play
with us a little more okay here we are
in our editor the folder we will be
using is right here so it is an empty
folder we can drag it and drop it on top
of Visual Studio code this is going to
open it up we are creating our main
python file and the widget file and we
put in our starter code for the widget
we can head over to the main file and
also put in our code and let's see if
this actually runs before we do anything
else this is my habit if we run we will
have our empty widget and we can start
doing our crazy things here let's come
back to the widget and remember we are
after a user interface like this the
first thing we're going to do is to set
up this group of check boxes we can do
that by coming up in our Constructor and
setting up that group I am going to put
in the code to save on some typing here
and I will do my best to explain this so
this is going to first to set up a group
box okay as I said it before you can
think of a group box as a container of
check boxes okay in this case we are
interested in check boxes suppose we
have three checkboxes in here we are
going to put them in a group box and it
will be this group box that we move
around but to have it set up we have to
actually set up our check boxes that's
what we do here we have one for Windows
one for Linux one for mac and once we
have the check boxes we will set up a
layout that is going to be within this
grouper box here so this is going to be
our layout and we will apply the layout
to the grouped box this is the setup we
have here take a moment to really
understand this it is a bit convoluted
but once you understand this it's going
to be a piece of cake to work with
checkboxes and radio buttons in your QT
applications okay we have our checkbox
but we can't really see it yet let's see
what I can do to be able to see this and
increase the complexity of our user
interface as we go I think this is going
to be a good exercise what we can do is
set up a layout so let's say layout and
we are going to say QV box layout it's
going to be a vertical layout we will
add our operating system group box to
the layout add the widget I want to get
autocomplete here because I am lazy so
we want to add OS which is a group box
and we want to set the layout to the
current widget here so we're going to
say self set layout and we want the
layout applied I think if we run we
should see our checkboxes showing on our
user interface so let's do this we're
going to show the terminal and run and
what do we have here no attribute
Windows tackled so we have connections
that are not working yet let's comment
this out because they are going to just
give us a hard time here and we can try
to run again and if we do notice what we
see we have our group books and we have
our check boxes and we can check them
all if we want or we can check two or we
can check one because this is not
exclusive so you can have multiple ones
selected and once we have these we may
be interested in getting the information
out of these guys for example if the
user checks windows we want to do
something in our application to take
into account that the user choose the
window checkbox here and
by connecting to the toggled signal so
we're going to set up these slots here
let's activate these connections that we
did here and I think we can put a space
in here to make it easier to read and
let's put in these implementations so
let's go all the way to the bottom where
we have our Constructor defined and we
are going to Define our 2 or 3 method
implementations notice that we have a
parameter how do I know we have a
parameter well I read the documentation
for the signals for checkbox let's go
there to do this together so that you
can really see what is going on here
let's do Q check box but it is the same
thing you have for Q push button so it's
kind of a repetition here but I am going
to show you that anyway if you look you
see that we don't have the signals the
same behavior we saw for the Q push
button but we can go to the parent class
and what this says is that really 2
checkbox has a lot of things it shares
with Q push button it just happens to
display differently but because it
inherits Q abstract button it shares
many behaviors with Q push button I want
you to keep that in mind let's go to Q
abstract button if we go to signals we
will see that we have a toggled signal
that happens to send a parameter and
this is what we are going to catch and
to decide whether the radio pattern is
checked or not checked this is really
cool let's come back to our code and we
can look at our method here if checked
we will so that it is checked if it's
not checked we will say that it is
unchecked the same applies to Linux and
Mac here we have done the connections so
this should work if we run the
application let's show our terminal
window clear and take out all this
garbage we have here and we will run if
we check window cells Windows is checked
if we uncheck windows it's unchecked
let's do the same for Linux you see it
works let's do the same format you see
it works this is really how you can
process this information in your QT
applications now that we have this we
can set up an exclusive set of check
boxes let's go down and do that and I
think we can go down below here and say
exclusive checkboxes and this is going
to be allowing the user to choose ranks
this is what we do as an example here
and what we do here we will set up a
group box
okay just like we did for check boxes
and we will set up a beer checkbox a
juice checkbox and a coffee checkbox we
will set the beer one checked by default
you can do this programmatically adjust
the left in this line to be able to show
you this and we will set up a logical
grouping of these buttons so that we
have the ability to set them to be
exclusive so this is how you make them
exclusive once you have this you will
set up the layout like we did for the
other checkboxes we will add them to the
layout and we will apply the layout to
the drinks group box here once we have
this we can add this to our user
interface but we will have to change the
layout a bit for example we can change
this to be a horizontal layout okay we
can do this and after this we will add
the other group box which is going to be
containing our drinks let's copy the
name here because I tend to forget these
things and mess up so let's do layout
add widget and we will be adding our
drinks group box if we run we should see
this showing up on our user interface
let's do terminal and run you see we
have our drinks and because this is an
exclusive set of check boxes we can only
choose one at a given time unlike what
we can do with the other one for the
operating system so you can choose
whatever you want in your QT
applications let's show you how to work
with radio buttons and the behavior is
really going to be the same so we can go
down and set up a set of radio buttons
let's do that I am going to go down here
and do that we have our radio buttons
here again we have a group box which is
going to group them together we set up
the radio buttons we set one to be
checked by default and we will set up a
layout that is going to be applied to
the group box we added things to the
layout and we apply the layout to our
group box here and if we want we can add
this to our I think we put our code here
in the wrong spot so let's cut this out
we don't want to mess up our layout here
so we just go below the group for
exclusive check boxes and we will put
our code in here sorry for that if it
was confusing and we will go down and
add this to the layout so we can say
layout add Twitter and that's going to
be answers I think so let's do that
answers and if we run okay we can run
the application we will have our fan
here if you want we can even achieve
what we saw in the slides here so all we
have to do is set up a vertical layout
and add the radio buttons to the bottom
of the vertical layout we can do that we
already know how to do that let's come
back to our code so what we need to do
is to take this guy here out of our
horizontal layout and we will set up a
vertical layout that is going to be the
actual layout of the user interface so
let's say we layout equals QV box layout
and we will name this horizontal layout
to be self-descriptive here I don't want
the code to be confusing good names are
really important you should focus on
that make sure the names describe what
you are doing in your user interface we
have the vertical layout so what we do
with the vertical layout we will add
the horizontal layout so let's do V
layout add layout and we will be adding
the H layout that we have set up in our
code and after this we will be adding
the answers group of radio buttons so
let's do the layout add widget answers
answers and we will be setting V layout
as our layout here I hope you can
understand this
if you don't please go back to the point
where we talked about layout in a bunch
of Widgets or you can even ask me I will
do the best I can to help you out let's
view our terminal and we can clear and
run if we run we will have our user
interface and ladies and gentlemen this
is what we set out to do in this lecture
I hope you found it interesting we are
going to stop here in this one and I
will see you in the next lecture in this
lecture we are going to look at The Cue
list widget component this is a
component that allows you to lay out
things in a list in a widget so for
example you can set up a widget like
this and we have a list of things we
have one two three we can even add more
and we will see how to do that and you
can really use it if you need this kind
of list in your user interface in this
lecture we will see how to set it up so
we will set up a class and set up our
widget we will see how to add items we
will see how to remove items we will see
how to get how many items are in our
list we will see how to get selected
items and we will get the list of items
and print them out to really give you a
foundation on using this component in
your own QT applications this is how
we're going to set it up we will have a
list widget component and this is going
to be our variable once you have it you
can choose to set the selection mode and
what this really means is whether you
allow users to only select a single item
or to be able to select multiple items
and you can control this using this
setting here you can add items using the
add item or add items method and you can
connect to a bunch of signals to know
whether the current item has changed or
whether the current text has changed and
you can check the documentation to see
other signals that are offered by this
component down below we are setting up a
bunch of buttons to be able to play with
this component and you can see that we
can also set up a bunch of methods that
are going to be triggered when we do
things in our list widget for example
this method is going to be triggered
whenever the current item changes we
will be able to print the new current
item we will be able to respond when the
current text changes we will be able to
call this method to add items and really
all these methods to do all kinds of
crazy things now that you know this we
are going to head over to visual studio
code and play with us a little more here
we are in our editor this is going to be
our current project folder it is empty
as you can see now let's drag it and
drop it on top of Visual Studio code
here this is going to open our project
and we can create our files so we needed
the widget file and we will put in our
starter code which is going to give us
an empty widget with a title here we can
head over to the main file and put in
the code that you are familiar with by
now and we can view our terminal to try
and run the application to make sure
this is working as we want let's run it
this will pop up our empty widget here
the first thing we want to do is to set
up our list widget and we have the
needed components imported if you go to
the top here you see that we are
importing Q list widget we can go down
and create a variable for this which is
going to be a member of this class here
because of the self thing we are doing
here this is our list widget we need to
give it a parent and we say that we want
to be able to select multiple items
using this setting here once we do that
we are going to add items you can either
add a single item using the add item
method as you see here or you can use
the add items method once we have this I
think we can set up a layout let's use a
vertical layout so we are going to say V
layout QV box layout and we are going to
say V layout add the widget add the
widget that's going to be
self with list we get and we will set
this layout to be used by the current
widget here so we're going to say self
set layout
and we will use vla out here and I think
if we run we will see our list widget
with the three items of data that we
have added so let's view terminal
and run this and if we do this you see
that we have one two three and this is
what you can do with a list widget now
that we have this we can connect to a
bunch of signals from cue list widget
but before we do that I think it is a
good idea to come back to the
documentation so let's say Q list we get
here and we can look at what it has to
offer I do recommend reading as much as
you can on this especially if it is the
first time you use this component here
so come to more look at what you can do
with that if you go to the top you're
going to see a bunch of signals you can
use if we can find them you see we have
a lot of signals that we can play with
we have a lot of slots we can play with
make sure you look at those that
interest you and read the documentation
to really know what these things do
let's come back to our application and
we will put in a bunch of connections
here once we have the list widgets set
up we will connect to the current item
changed signal and the current text
change the signal and if you want to
know what these signals do again use the
documentation to your advantage current
item changed let's see what happens here
current item changed if we go to the
signal this property holds the row of
the current item they don't say anything
about this signal here
and this is a bummer this is really bad
because QT should
say at least something about this but
they don't this is going to be triggered
when you change the current item in your
list widget if you wanted to see a good
documentation for QT for example if you
think that the documentation for acute
for python is lacking in some way you
can use the C plus documentation and all
you have to do is say queue list widget
and say qt6 for example this is going to
give you the C plus plus documentation
okay I think I should have said this
somewhere I will update the course to be
able to say that so we have cue list
widget if we go down we see the
properties
let's look at the signals current item
changed and at least they say what the
signal does this is what I mean when I
say that the python documentation is
still lacking so if you want you can use
the C plus documentation like I do here
or you can use the python documentation
we have been using all along let's come
back to our project and we need to set
up these methods that are going to be
triggered when these signals are fired
we can go down and put in our method
definitions you can do that we have
current item changed and you see the
signal is going to give us the current
item the new item if I can say it like
that and the current text change the
signal is going to give us the new text
let's try to run this and see what
happens so view terminal and run this
and I think the application is still
running but no big deal we can run it
again
let's go to
okay so let's run
and if we click on one this is the
current item if we click on two we see
current item and we can click on three
to see the current item and they tell
you that the current item text has
changed so you can use these signals if
you want in your QT application okay now
that we have this working we can add a
bunch of buttons that will allow us to
manipulate our list widget for example
we might want to add a new item to get
to the current item count and things
like that let's do that so we will
create a bunch of buttons here and I
also put in the connections to be able
to connect to the slots directly to save
on some time once we have this we will
add these buttons to our layout so let's
do that we will say video add widget add
widget should type that button add item
this is the thing we can copy this
shift out down to copy the line the
other is going to be button delete item
let's do that delete item
we can copy again line that's going to
be button item count button item count
and the last one is going to be button
selected items and once we have this we
should see our buttons in the user
interface let's see if we actually see
them view terminal run the application
and the button add item clicked connect
itself add item what is going on here we
don't have the the method
implementations for the slots we are
connecting to our signals so I think it
is a good time to add them here so what
we can do we can come down to the bottom
and I think it is a good idea to
actually separate this method
definitions okay so let's do that this
one is going to be triggered when we
want to add a new item and you can see
how we are adding a new item we are just
calling the add item on our list widget
component if we wanted to get the item
count we call the count method on our
list widget if we want to delete delete
an item okay we will call the take item
method on our list widget and we will
give it the character row okay and this
is going to remove the currently
selected item this is how we are doing
these things here if you want you can
Loop through all the selected items and
you get a list of selected items by
calling the selected items method and
you can Loop through this list printing
each item's text this is how we do this
so let's try and run the application now
we can clear and run now the application
is going to come up okay if we add item
you see we are adding a new item this
guy is going to be triggered let me make
sure you can see this if we click delete
item this is going to delete the
currently selected item let's make sure
the currently selected item is 2 here if
we delete two is going to go away if we
click one is going to go away and if we
delete new item is going to go away and
you see that we have a problem because
now current item changed is not going to
find the current item to print so this
is a problem you might want to fix but
we're not going to handle errors here
you can handle them in whatever way you
usually handle errors in your python
applications this is really all I had to
share in this lecture showing you how to
use the list widget component you can
use it if you want to show a list of
items in your widget applications and
you can check the documentation to see
more things you can even do then I had a
chance to tell you about in this lecture
here I am going to stop here in this
lecture and I will see you in the next
one in this lecture we are going to look
at the queue tab widget component this
is a component that allows you to set up
a user interface like this in which you
have multiple parts of your user
interface that you want to tell go
through for example here we have the
same widget shown in two states the
first report is going to show this
information here the second part is
going to show these buttons but you can
toggle between these by clicking on
these titles here so if you click on
information it is going to show this
little widget if you click on buttons it
is going to toggle to the state down
here and you are able to toggle between
different parts of your user interface
this is good if you want to set up
settings for your application for
example and there are many uses for this
kind of widget we are going to see how
to set it up in your QT applications and
we will see how to add tabs and how to
use components inside separate tabs the
first step to working with this is to
create an instance of it in your python
application so that's what we have right
here
and after that we will create our sub
widgets if I can call them like that the
first one is going to show information
it's going to be an instance of Q widget
and we will put things inside okay so we
have a level and we have a line edit and
we will set up a layout that is going to
be containing this level and the line
edit as we do here and we will apply the
layout to our widget here we also set up
a bunch of buttons so button one through
button three We'll add the buttons to
the layout and we set to the layout to
the widget here once we have these sub
widgets we will add them to our tab
widget by calling the add tab method as
you see right here once we do that we
will specify the widget we want to add
and the title information for that
widget once we do that we will set up a
layout that is going to apply to our
container widget and we apply the layout
to our widget here and once we finish
this setup we can run the application
and we will see something like this
pop-up now that we notice we can head
over to visual studio code and actually
do this okay here we are in our Visual
Studio code editor the project is going
to be leaving in this folder here 12 Hue
tab widget you can drag it and drop it
on top of Visual Studio code here the
first thing we want to do is to create
our files so that's going to be
mainly.py and the other one is going to
be widget.py let's do that we can go in
our widget and set up our starter code
for the class it's going to be
inheriting from Q widget as usual make
sure you see the Imports we have here so
these are the things we're going to be
needing once we have this and we can go
to our main file and put in our starter
code if you don't want to type this code
you can copy from the resource section
of the lecture you're going to find the
code here you can even download from
GitHub if you want to have all the code
for the course in one place on your
local drive you can use the course
however you see fit let's go to terminal
and run this and we can run the main
file and this is going to give us an
empty widget on top of which we can
start setting up our qtab widget before
we even do anything I think it is a good
idea to go to the documentation and look
for q-tab widget Q tab widget so we can
open it for a cute for python here and
if you go to more you're going to read
all you can about this okay so make sure
you read this if it is the first time
you use this component here you can see
it has a bunch of signals it has a bunch
of thoughts you can really do all kinds
of crazy things let's come back to our
project here in our widget file and we
will set up our tab widget so let's do
tab widget equals Q tablet and we will
pass a current after that we will set up
our sub widgets just like we showed in
the slide so I am just going to put in
the code here first one is going to be
information which is going to take the
full name of a person and we will store
that in the memory of our application
after we have the components set up we
are going to add them to a layout that
we will then apply to our widget here
this is going to set up our widget here
we will set up another sub widget which
is going to be a widget containing a
bunch of buttons one two and three here
we are just connecting to the button to
show you that you can respond to this
clicked signal from this button and once
we have these guys we can add them to
our tab widget so let's go down and do
that we are going to say add tabs to
widget and we will say tab with it add
tab we can do that you see that you can
really add a lot of things you can even
add action if you want to you know what
this method does please use the
documentation for now we will just add
the tab and the first one
is going to be widget form let's do that
and the text is going to be information
we will add another one tap widget add
Tab and that's going to be widget
buttons and we can say buttons here you
can really put in whatever text you want
so why do we have this squiggle here it
must be Visual Studio code getting
confused now that we have this we will
actually set up the layout let's do that
so layout equals QV box layout it's
going to be a vertical layout because
that's what I prefer we will add the
things to the layout and what we add is
going to be we need to put a comma here
okay let's make sure we do that
and we put in a closing double coot now
we can do add widget and add our tab
widget once we do that we will set the
layout to be used by our entire widget
here so self set layout and that's going
to be our layout here if we have this
and run the application we should see
our tab widget let's make sure we view
our terminal and to make sure we can run
this but before we do I know a problem
we're going to have we have a connection
to a slot which we don't have defined
yet so let's go down and do that before
we actually try to run So Def we Define
the slot it's going to be a member and
in the slot we print button clicked we
can do that now we can actually try to
run the application the code is going to
auto save now you see we have our tab
widget exactly like we saw
in the slides you can resize this if we
want this is going to be the minimum
size by default we can type in something
the first let's say John snow or we can
change to the other thing click on
button one you see our slot is
responding if you want you can also
connect to these other buttons but again
the main point is to show you how to use
qtap widget in your QT applications and
this concludes what I had to share in
this lecture I hope you found it
interesting I will see you in the next
one in this lecture we are going to look
at the Q combo box component this is a
component that allows for the user to
choose between a selection of items and
it is easier to show it than to talk
about it so the component looks like
this when you click on this little icon
this is going to pop up allowing the
user to choose something and if they
choose something that's going to be the
current item in the combo box here this
is how you use it you can get to the
camera diagram and use the data to do
things in your QT application let's see
how you can set it up and here is the
code you created by using cucumber box
just like we do for other components
this is going to give us a variable that
we can work with in our application once
you have the variable you can use it to
add items to the combo box and these are
going to be the set of things the user
can choose through we will use a bunch
of buttons to play with combo box for
example we can get to the current value
we can set a new value to the combo box
we will see how to do that and this is
really going to set the current value
and we will get the values in our combo
box we can do things like this and down
below we have a bunch of buttons that
are going to help us use this and let's
take a look at the slots that we will be
using to get to the current value we
will be calling the current text method
and we can also call the method to get
the current index if you need that in
your QT application we can also set to
the current item by passing in the index
so we will say the current item is the
second item in the list or the item that
is at index 2 and because indexes start
at zero this is going to be the third
item in the list you need to be careful
about this if you want you can even get
all the values in your combo box and
here we set up a simple Loop to Loop
through the items printed each item at
an even index in your combo box now that
you know this we can head over to visual
studio code and actually play with us
here we are in our working folder the
current project is Q combo box you can
see that it is empty here let's drag it
and drop it on top of Visual Studio code
and we will create the files that we
need we have main.py the python file the
main python file and we have widget Dot
py and we will put in our starter code
we can also go in the main python file
and put in our main code and once we do
that we can bring up our terminal window
and try to run the application to see if
we see our trusty empty widget here we
have it let's go back to widget here and
we will go down and set up our combo box
it is really nothing special you already
know how to do that from the slides so
we will create create our combobox
component we are using self here because
we want it to be a member of this class
and that's going to give us the ability
to call it from methods because we are
using a bunch of methods here that are
going to be manipulating our combo box
so let's do that we have our thing here
okay now we have the combo box we have
a bunch of buttons that we can use to
manipulate the combobox now we want to
lay things out so we will set up a
layout and use that layout on this
widget here let's go down and do that we
will use a vertical layout as we always
do let's align this properly so we will
have our vertical layout we will add our
combo box we will add our buttons and we
will set this layout as the layout for
the current widget let's run and see
view terminal like we always do if we
run we should see our thing here and now
you can look at what a combobox says it
is this thing on top which says Earth if
we click on this down error we will have
an option to choose one of the planets
here for example we can choose Mars but
we can also use these buttons to
manipulate things in our combo box on
top here let's put in the methods and I
am going to explain them one by one
because now you are a master at using QT
so many of these things I don't need to
explain line by line by typing each one
so let's go down and put in our methods
the first method is going to be getting
the current value and it is going to be
using a bunch of methods on the Q combo
box class let's go to the documentation
and actually show you the documentation
for this
I really encourage you to use the
documentation as much as you can kill
combo box
and we open this up you can read more
you can see the methods the slots the
signals you can use to play with us you
can really do all kinds of crazy things
let's come back to our project so you
can look at current text and current
index we will use the Set current index
method to set the current index and we
can Loop through the values in our combo
box printing the text and the current
index we might be at in our Loop let's
view terminal and run the application to
see this running we will see our user
interface here and if we get the current
value and you see that the current value
is Earth we can select Mars for example
if we print current value it's going to
say Mars at index 2 we can select proton
if we get current value it's going to
say the current value and the index and
we are able to do that because of the
current value method we have set up here
we can set the current value to be
something at index 2 and that's going to
be Mars if we get to the current value
we're going to get Mars we can print all
the values we have in our ascent and the
indexes and this is working exactly as
we want this is really all I had to
share in this lecture I hope you found
it interesting we are going to stop here
in this one and I will see you next time
in this lecture we're going to see a way
you can design layouts and user
interfaces without hard coding them in
your python code like we have been doing
so far and we will be using QT designer
QT designer is a tool that allows us to
build user interfaces just by dragging
and dropping components and that's going
to give us a cool user interface we can
just Import in our python code and use
it right away the user interface is
going to look something like this this
is just a simple introduction we will
have time to install this tool and see
how to use it but you can see the idea
here for example to set up this button I
did here all I had to do was to drag and
drop this UI component on my formula
here and that's going to give me a
format you can use and you can see we
can do all kinds of crazy things on top
here you can see we can do a bunch of
layouts we can really build all kinds of
crazy interfaces using cute designer so
this chapter is going to be about using
cute designer we will see how to install
it we will see how to create these UI
files and we will see different ways we
have to import this user interface files
into our PI site 6 applications and
that's going to be really cool once you
design your UI files what you will get
out of QT designer is a DOT UI file and
it is this kind of file that we will be
importing in our PI side application one
thing you should know is that we have
two way to get access to QT designer you
can use the QT designer application that
comes bundled into your QT installation
or you can use cutecreator one thing I
have to say which is a bit inconvenient
is that we don't have immediate access
to these tools when we install Pi side
like we have done so far so what we will
do in this lecture is install QT which
is going to give us access to the these
design tools we will install the C plus
plus side of QT that's what we are going
to install here and that's going to give
us access to QT designer and cute
Creator to install QT all you have to do
is come to your browser and say QT
download that's going to give you a
length looking something like this let's
open it okay once you are at the QT
website you can see we are at qtio slash
download once you are here you will
click on download try and on this page
here we can scroll all the way to the
bottom and say download for open source
users because we are just interested in
the open source version of QT so click
on go open source here and once you are
on this page you will scroll all the way
to the bottom where it says download the
QT online installer and you will click
on this button they are probably going
to detect your operating system once
they do you will come all the way to
this the location here and hit download
and this should start to download in the
QT for you here you can see that it is
downloading from me but I already have
this so all you need to do is to wait
for this to download open this file and
let it install QT once you have that
file downloaded you will double click on
it or click on it to start installing QT
once you do that you will get a user
interface like this asking you to login
so if you don't have an account you will
create it once you have your account and
your credentials you will just hit next
here and you will go through a series of
steps helping you install QT one thing I
should say is that if you get a list of
options telling you what you should
install make sure you click on custom
installation that's going to land you
where we are about to go in a minute I
can't really show you the exact steps
because I already have QT installed on
my system here so I am going to do the
best I I can to guide you through this
but if you choose custom installation
and then hit next you are going to land
in a place like this once you are here I
want you to click on QT and if you click
on that you are going to get a series of
options make sure you choose the latest
version the latest version at the time
of this recording is
qt640 as you see here that's what I am
going to choose I am going to expand
that and I am showing you the steps here
for Windows and they are going to be
similar for Linux and Mac once you are
here on Windows you can either choose
minty W here or msvc I do recommend
using minty W because it is hassle free
it's going to be easier to install this
if you use msvc here you will need to
have the Microsoft Visual Studio IDE
installed so if you don't want the
visual studio thing just use mintyw here
it is going to give you everything you
need if you are on Linux you are
probably going to see a GCC version here
if you are on a Mac you are going to see
something saying clang or whatever so
make sure you check one just like I have
minty W checked here and you are going
to click on this button that says next
door install or something once you do
that you will keep hitting next until
you start installing you will age for QT
to be installed and at the end you will
have a QT installation on your system
one thing I should say is that mine is
installed in cqt which is going to be
the default suggested by QT so after you
install QT you will have a cutie folder
in your C drive or wherever you
instructed the installer to install your
QT files on your system okay once you
have it installed on your start menu you
will have an option to start QT creator
you can see I can start it here let's
start it to show you how it looks
okay this is how QT Creator is going to
look if you start it up you can do all
kinds of crazy things but at this moment
we are interested in using QT designer
which is bundled into QT Creator if you
start QT designer we also have the
option to start it let's say designer
and if we do we will have designer
whatever the version you have installed
so if we started we will have it pop up
on our screen and we can start using it
and this concludes what we set out to do
in this lecture here introducing cute
designer and showing you different ways
you can have access to it you can either
use QT designer or QT Creator and we
were able to get access to these things
by installing QT just like we did in
this lecture here we are going to stop
here in this lecture and I will see you
in the next one in this lecture we are
going to see how to work with QT
designer and we have access to this
because we installed qt in the last
lecture which gave us access to either
QT designer or acutecreator what we will
be doing in this lecture is to try and
create a user interface like this it's a
simple form allowing the user to type in
their full name and occupation once they
do that they can click on the submit
button and we can grab all this
information and use that in our python
application or a pi side application
whatever you might want to call and once
you have this information you can use
that in your Pi side application so
let's start the QT designer to start it
you come to your starter menu whatever
start menu you have on your operating
system we can type QT for designer I
think that's going to give us access to
this once you start it it should show up
like this it is going to show you a
window that lets you create a form we
may choose not to use this because I
wanted to show you around so I am going
to click close on that and what I want
you to see is that we will be storing
our files into this folder in our source
code saying using QT designer so make
sure you have a location where you will
save your user interface files and to
create a new form all you have to do is
come to file new and you see this is
going to give us back that user
interface we had so let's see the
options we have down here so we can
create a dialog with buttons at the
bottom we can create a dialog with
buttons to the right we can create a
dialog without buttons or we can create
a main window or a widget you can see
that we can create a lot of things I
think I am going to go for the dialogue
without buttons because we will be
putting in our own button remember the
design we are going after it is
something like this so this is just
going to be an empty form a dialog
without buttons on top of which we will
be building our own user interface let's
come back to designer okay we're going
to choose this so let's click create
Metro you have dialog without buttons
selected here and you will click on
create here so let's come back it's
going in our dialogue without buttons
create this is going to create our file
and once you have this thing created
uh we don't want to create a dialogue
for what we want because if you go back
to our user interface here this is not a
dialogue really we want this to be some
kind of widget so let's go back and make
sure we create a widget because it is
important which class you start by so
let's discard the changes that we had
and we want to create the widget sorry
for that make sure you create a widget
here and come back here and say create
that's going to give you a widget and
one thing that is really important when
you create your user interface files
like this is to remember the object name
for your top level widget here and in
this case you can see that it it is
called the form we want to go back and
call this widget
just like I did here make sure you name
yours with it and we can start doing our
thing if you remember we have a bunch of
levels and line edits in our user
interface that we are after here you can
see that the thing we have on the left
here is a level and this thing is a line
edit and it is the same on the second
line here and this is a button let's
make sure we add these things into our
designer user interface if you want to
search for a component you can type the
name here we are looking for a label so
you see if we type a lip here we're
going to get level you can drag two
levels because they think we just need
the two you can close here by clicking
on the X that's to the right of this
component here and down below we can
grab the button and put it on our user
interface we also need a line edit
let's type line edit and you see we have
it right here we can drag one here and
we can drag another one here and we have
everything we need in our user interface
we can name these things so let's say
full name okay we can type in whatever
we want and the other one is going to
say occupation
if I remember correctly down here we are
going to say submit in the text and I am
just double clicking in these components
to have the ability to type text so
nothing really complicated here and now
that I have my components here the next
important thing is to name the
components that I think I will be using
on the python side of my application
here and I will be using these line
edits and the submit button so the user
will be able to type text in here and I
want to be able to grab that text on the
python side and I want to know when the
user clicks on this submit button here
so let's name our thanks I am going to
click on either of these and come to
object name in my properties to the
right here so this one is going to be
named full name
line edit okay so the other one is going
to be occupation line added
and the other thing I need to name is my
submit button okay make sure you
remember these names and at any point
you can open this file here and look at
this if you click you're going to see
the object name to the right in the
Tuple here so you can see your object
name here if we click the other one we
can see our object name right here if we
click on the button we can see our
object name right here and as I said
before make sure you name your top level
widget in this case it is named widget
here and this is going to be important
when we get to the point where we load
this on our python side so this is
really important once we have this user
interface I think we need to put in a
bunch of layouts and it is really easy
to use layouts from QT designer for
example we wanted the full name and the
line edit here to be laid out
horizontally so we can click on full
name and our line edit while having
control selected so we can select them
all all or we can even click and drag
and make sure we have them selected here
we can do something like this once you
have them selected you can come to the
top here where you have these buttons
the first one is going to help you lay
things out horizontally the second one
is going to help you lay things out
vertically we want to lay out
horizontally so we can hover over this
button you see it says layout
horizontally if we click on it these
guys are going to be aligned
horizontally in a layout we are going to
do the same for occupation and the line
edit to the right of that we are going
to put them in a horizontal layout and
we want to click on the form here and
lay everything out vertically because
that's the user interface we are after
so click somewhere empty on the form
come to the button that says layout
vertically if you click on it things are
going to be laid out vertically and we
can resize our user interface to make it
really look nice here I think this is
good and we have our user interface so
you can come to file and save it and you
are going to choose the location where
you want to save yours okay this is
where we want to save our file we will
give it a name let's name it widget
dot UI we can do something like this and
if we save it is going to be saved and
we are done with our design of our user
interface here okay now that we are done
with this we are going to head over in
the next lecture and show you how you
can do the same from QT Creator and
after that we will worry about importing
this user interface for use in your Pi
side application that's going to be
really cool so I will see you in this
lecture
in this lecture we are going to look at
how we can load our user interface files
into a python application there are
different ways to do this as I mentioned
in a previous lecture probably but we
will be looking at a class called Q UI
loader which helps us do that let's go
to the documentation and actually see
what this class does you can come to
your research engine and say hi site
sucks loader
if I can type today this is going to
give us a link we can click on and if we
go there we're going to learn or we can
about this class here they show a little
example of how you can use this we will
be running a version of this example in
our PI side application but make sure
you read about this class to know what
it does let's come back to the slides
and really look at how to use this
so to use this class you have to make
sure you have imported Qui loader like
we are doing here once you do that you
will create a loader object just like we
do here once you have a loader object
all you have to do to load your UI file
is to call the load method just like we
are doing here so the first parameter is
going to be your UI file and what this
says is that in this example here we
will be putting our python file in the
same location as our user interface file
if your user interface file lives in
another folder you will have to tell
your python file to go to that location
and find the UI file that's something
you need to know and once we call the
load method here we will get a widget
that we can then use in our application
like we use any other widget another
thing worth mentioning is that to access
things into our UI file we we will be
using the notation here notice that we
are saying full name line edit because
it is the name we used in our UI file
remember the object name that's the name
you have to use here and then we say dot
and access properties of this UI
component you see we are doing the same
for our occupation line edit to access
the text another thing we can do is
connect slots to signals coming from the
user interface for example here you see
that we are saying whenever somebody
clicks on the submit button in our
window object we want to respond in our
do something slot that we have defined
on top here and once you have this you
will show the window you will call the
exact method to kick off the event Loop
and your application is going to show up
and do things one thing I wanted to warn
you about is that the loading that we
are doing here is happening at runtime
and what that means is that your
application will be paying a performance
penalty every time the user runs your
application that's why I am really not
in favor of using Q UI loader to load
your user interface files because the
penalty is going to be on your users and
you will be wasting their time there is
a better way to do this and I will show
that in the next few lectures but for
now you need to be aware of Q UI loader
I think Q UI loader can be useful if you
are prototyping and things like that but
in a production application you
shouldn't really use this at least
that's my opinion here okay make sure
that you know that q u i loader is going
to make your users pay the price every
time the application runs now that you
notice we are going to head over a 2o
editor and play with us a little more
okay here we are in our editor which is
Visual Studio code this is the folder
where we will be doing our things here
the first thing I want you to do is to
make sure that I put my UI file in this
project here we can either use the one
from QT designer or QT Creator let's
grab the one from QT creator doesn't
really make a difference they are the
same so I am going to put in my UI file
and once I do that I will open this
project in Visual Studio code let's do
that okay the project is opened you can
see that we have our UI file what we
want to do is to create our main Pi file
first thing we want to do is to make
sure we import the components we need
and we import cute widgets because we
will be using the widget that q u i
loader is going to load we create our
daughter object nothing special here
next we go down and create our
application instance so it's going to be
a queue application object that we call
app here we will have a widget or a
window that we get by loading our our
user interface file it is not called
user data UI it is called the widget.ui
so let's make sure we correct this a
little bit once we call the load method
this is going to give us a widget that
we can manipulate in our application
here we can go down and Define the
function that is going to respond when
the user manipulates things in a user
interface so this is a do something
function again it is going through our
window object to access the components
we have in our designer form let's make
sure we open designer because ah we
still have this opened in QT Creator so
if we go to the line edit again you can
come to the object name here and see the
object name this is what we will be
accessing from our python application so
let's make sure we know that let's close
out of QT Creator here and we are
setting up our window type title on our
window object and hopefully this proves
that this is a real widget that we can
manipulate like we have been
manipulating the widgets that we have
created ourselves and this is really
cool okay let's go down and finish this
up we will connect and respond when the
submit button is clicked then we will
show our widget here and kick off the
event Loop so the real meat of this is
where we create our daughter object this
is how you create it and the other thing
is where we load our widget UI file and
that's the line here what we call the
load method we will be getting a window
object which is really a widget and we
can do things we are used to do on other
widgets for example we can set window
title we can access things using the dot
notation like we do here and this is
really cool now that we have this we can
actually try and run the application
here let's show a a terminal window like
we always do hopefully this is going to
work it's not going to blow up in our
face
fingers crossed and we can go up and try
to run our python file and look at this
look at what we have here full name
occupation let's put in Daniel
gray for our full name occupation let's
say I am a farmer and if I hit submit
Daniel gray is a farmer let's say I am a
plumber
Daniel gray is a plumber and this is
really cool we are able to use our UI
file from our python file but again
every time the user runs the application
notice what's going to happen you know
this widget UI file is going to be
transformed into Python and the python
is going to be loaded into this file
here all of that Machinery is going to
be really going on when your application
runs and this is going to make your
users pay a performance penalty whenever
they run your application so this is
really not good but you need to be aware
of this in case you have a logical use
case for this this is really all I had
to share in this lecture I hope you
found it useful before I go make sure
you remember your object names it is
through these object names you go to
access components from your UI file in
your python application here this is
really cool in the next lecture we will
try to reorganize this code in a
separate file to make it really easy to
manage and play with this a little more
so I will see you in the next lecture in
this lecture we are going to reorganize
our code using Q UI loader and Export
that into a separate class so that our
main python file is a bit cleaner we're
not going to do anything special really
it is the same thing we did in the last
lecture but here is our loader object
that we create in a separate file we
will set up a class that we call user
interface that is going to be inheriting
Q object because we need to connect
signals to slots that's why we need to
do this and then in our Constructor we
will be doing our loading we will set up
a UI object that you see here which is a
member of this class this is really
going to be a widget that we get by
calling the load method like we did in
the last lecture once we do that we set
our window title we do our connection to
the button and we set up our slots that
is going going to respond and this is
really all we need to do here another
thing is that we have a show method that
we are going to call to make this user
interface show up nothing special here
once we have this class we will import
it in our main python file you see we
are creating an object of it like we do
here and we are showing it and once we
created the wire end to the actual UI
file is going to be done in the
Constructor by the time we call the show
method here the entire window is going
to be set up and we will see it pop up
on our screen nothing really special
here we are just reorganizing what we
already had in the last lecture but
let's head over to our editor and
actually do this
okay here we are in our editor we will
be working in this folder here you can
see that it is empty before we do let's
head over to the lecture where we
created our widget file and steal it and
put a copy of that in our current folder
here once we have this we will open this
up in Visual Studio code and we will
create our main python file so let's
make sure we do that okay plus
main.py we also need the user interface
file let's say user interface
dot py which is going to be doing the
heavy lifting and bringing in our user
interface file that we got from cute
designer in this case I am just going to
paste in the class because you already
know most of these things we will be
importing Qui loader once we have it
imported we will go in our Constructor
and load our user interface file in this
case our user interface file is named
widget.ui
okay so make sure you correct this a
little bit we will give it a window
title we will make the connection to the
button that is coming from our user
interface file again we know it is named
submit button because that's what we set
up in our designer file so let's bring
up designer because I think I really
need to show you this okay let's close
out of this and we will open our current
location we go in we can drag our widget
file and drop that on top of designer if
we go to the submit button it's object
name is submit button just like you see
here it is this exact name that we have
to load in our python file so this is
submit button if we go back in designer
submit button if you go to the full name
line edit the object name is right here
so if we come back to our file we should
be using that exact object name in our
file make sure you really follow this if
you mess these names up you're going to
be in for a lot of trouble now that we
have this we can head over in our main
python file so let's do that okay we can
put in the code and we will be importing
Pi site 6 and we will be importing our
user interface class from our user
interface file once we have all these in
we create our application object we will
create our window and it is going to be
an object of our user interface class
this line is going to trigger a call to
the Constructor that we have here and
the Constructor is going to be doing the
heavy lifting to load our widget UI file
and give us an object called UI that we
can manipulate in our application here
again the loading here is still
happening at run time make sure you know
this this is going to incur a
performance penalty to your users and
you don't really want to do that unless
you have a really good reason to use
this way of loading your user interface
files now that we have this I think we
can try to run the application and see
how it behaves we can show our terminal
and we can clear and if we run our
python file we should see our thing here
exactly like we did in the last lecture
if we put in our full name
and our occupation let's say we are
farmers farmer submit we have farmer if
we put in Plumber just like we did in
the last lecture we will get to the same
thing and this is really all we set out
to do in this lecture now that you know
how to use Q UI loader we will head over
into that structure and show you how we
can actually compile our user interface
file into python code and that's going
to really take the performance penalty
and put that on you the developer so you
will take your user interface files and
turn them into python file and their
users will be loading those python files
when they run the application and that's
going to be much better let's head over
to the list lecture and do that in this
lecture we are going to see how to
compile our user interface files into
python code that we can directly Import
in our python project and the command to
do that is really simple it is what you
see here we have a tool that we have
access to because we installed Pi site
6. the tool is called Pi side 6 Dash UIC
once you call it you will give it your
widget user interface file and you got
this file from a designer or QT Creator
you will put in this arrow and then you
will specify the output file name and at
the convention I like to use is to say
UI Dash and say the name of the file
that I got from designer or QT Creator
so in this case it's going to be UI Dash
widget dot Pi file and this is going to
be the file that we get out of this user
interface compiler you can say you IC
stands for user interface combiner so if
we run our designer file in UIC here we
will get a file named exactly like this
and this is a convention I use to make
it easy for me to manage these files
especially if you have a really big
project it can be really hard to keep
track of this so make sure you
understand this naming convention once
you understand it you can modify it to
suit your own needs another thing I
would like to warn you about is to
remember the name of the top level
widget you have in your user interface
file in our case we named that widget
exactly like this and when we do that
the user interface compiler is going to
generate a class that we can then load
in our own python code and the
conversion the UIC compiler uses is to
say UI Dash widget this is going to be
the name of the class and this is what
we will try to manipulate populate in
our own python code and make sure you
really drill this in your brain because
if you don't you are going to have
mismatching names either in your user
interface code or in your python code
make sure these things match up another
thing I noticed when using this in
Visual Studio code is that the files
that I get out of my user interface
compiler were encoded in utf-16 and the
visual studio code would not understand
this I will show you how to bypass this
but I just want you to be aware of this
if you face this problem here and if you
are using a different editors you might
have to do research on how to get around
these problems and again make sure you
remember the convention we are using
here the widget that UI file is going to
be what we get from QT designer or QT
Creator the design file once we pass
that file into the user interface
compiler we will get a you I Dash
widget.py file this is a file generated
by the user interface compiler you have
no business manipulating it manually and
our widget.py file is going to be our
own class which is going to be trying to
reuse code that was generated for us by
the user interface compiler make sure
you really understand this convention I
will be going through this convention
again when we hit Visual Studio code in
a minute but I just want you to be aware
of this once we have our file generated
we will set up our own widget class like
this and again this is just a simple
widget we are creating this is our own
class name it is going to be inheriting
both Q widget and the UI widget UI
widget is the class that the user
interface compiler is going to generate
from your UI file again this is going to
work because our top level widget that
contains our user interface is named
widget let's go back to designer and
actually show you that I think we still
have designer opened if you manage to
click around on the lobbying form here
you will see that our object name is
widget and the user interface compiler
is going to pick this up and generate a
class that is named UI widget and it is
what we are trying to inherit from here
I really want you to notice this if you
have problems with us it might be really
hard to debug so once we have inherited
the correct class we will go in our
Constructor and because we are
inheriting from UI widget we have the
things that UI widget has and those
things are our submit button we can
access it like this our full name line
edit we can access it like this and our
occupation line edit and we can access
it like this again we know the object
names because they are what we set up in
our designer file let's make sure we
open this in designer if we go to the
full name line edit the object's name is
right here if we go to the occupation
line edit the object's name is right
here if we go to the submit button the
object name is going to be right here
for everybody to see make sure you
really know these things I don't want
you to face problems if you went through
this course to learn about Pi side 6.
okay once we have events set up we will
also set up our slot which is going to
respond when the user clicks on our
button and the connection is going to
make sure that whenever somebody clicks
on the button we will be called and this
slot here nothing complicated so far and
one benefit of doing this is that this
is going to be making it easy for your
users you went through the trouble to
transform your user interface files into
Python and the user is not going to be
paying that price you the developer will
be paying that price and it is really
good because you develop your
application once and your users will
probably be running the application a
thousand times or even a million times
depending on how successful your
application is so if you move the price
at the developer time you will be really
saving your users a lot of time with the
Q UI loader every instance of your
application that runs would pay that
price but now we are paying that price
once when we develop the application
that's the benefit of doing things this
way okay now that you know this we can
head over to visual studio code and play
with us a little more okay here we are
in our project this is going to be our
project folder here it is empty so what
we need to do is to steal the UI file
that we will be using for this demo here
so let's put this in place and I think
we can directly open this in Visual
Studio code so let's drag this and drop
on top of our editor here this is going
to give us our project we need to create
a few files remember our Diamond
convention we need a python file which
is going to be the main python file
let's do that we will also need to set
up a widget
dot py file
which is what is going to be important
things generated by our user interface
compiler now that we have the UI file
the first thing we need to do is to
compile it to python you already know
the command because we saw it in our
slides but I am going to show that again
right here so let's show our terminal
and make sure you see everything here
let's clear I am going to paste it in
the command but you can type it if you
want the command says Pi side 6 Dash UIC
after that we will specify the input
file which is going to be our user
interface file that we have here in our
folder we will specify an angle bracket
facing right this is how we use this
tool and you can say the output file
right here in our case it is going to be
ui-widget.py once you have this typed in
correctly you can hit enter the tool is
going to go to work and it is going to
generate a
ui-widget.py file that you see generated
here if you want you can even open this
in Visual Studio code so let's make sure
we click on it and you can see the
things that are generated for you by the
user interface compiler they say that
this file was created by the cute user
interface compiler this is the version
they warn you that changes to this file
may be lost to the next time in the user
interface combiner is run but you can
browse through it it is really a simple
class it's just doing the heavy lifting
of generating these layouts and things
for you so that you don't have to worry
about it if you go in you will see our
object names for example you see full
name line edit we see occupation line
edit if we go down I think we will find
our button and these are things we will
be loading in our python code one thing
I want you to notice though is that this
was generated in a UTF F16 encoding
Visual Studio code is using utf-8 if I
try to run this I will be into problems
so I will fix this in a minute when I
show you the problem but I just want you
to notice this here okay we have our UI
widget Pi file again
in a dynamic convention we are using
files we name like valves are going to
be what we get as output from the user
interface compiler files we named like
widget.py like this are going to be our
own code that uses what we got from the
user interface compiler make sure you
really understand this and widgets that
UI is going to be the file we got from
UI designer I know this may be confusing
but once you do this a couple of times
this is going to become second nature
let's set up our own widget Pi file and
I am just going to paste that in here
because I don't want to waste your time
typing this it is going to be a class
that inherits both Q widget and UI
widget this is super important we set up
our Constructor which is going to call
the set UI method and this is a way QT
provides to wire to the class that was
generated for you you don't have to
worry too much about this just make sure
you put in this call once you do that
you will have access to everything we
had in our user interface file for
example we can set up the window title
because this is a widget we can access
the submit button like this we use the
self thing here because now that's part
of us because we are inheriting from UI
widget and UI widget is named like this
because our object name is Widget the
top level widget is named widget if we
go back to designer that's what we
should see here let's click on the top
level with it again make sure you see
this object name here this is important
this has to match what you have after
the UI Dash here this is how the user
interface compiler is going to do things
so once we have everything we will set
up our slot and everything is really
going to work once we have this we can
go to our main main dot python file and
we will put in the code which is not
going to be anything new so we will
create our application object we will
create an instance of our own widget
this is really important so notice the
class is named widget we are creating an
instance of it and this is going to show
our user interface because we did the
wiring in the Constructor of our widget
class here now that you have all this
done we can try to run the application
and a warn you it's not going to work at
this point but let's try to do that
so we can say python
main.py and if we try to do that we will
have an error what is it saying uh
source code strength cannot contain null
bytes and this is happening because our
UI widget Pi file was generated in any
coding that is different from the one
that is being used by Visual Studio code
here so what we need to do in our case
we can click on this utf-16 thing down
below once we do we will have a menu on
top here in Visual Studio code and what
I want you to do is to click on save
with including and we will be using
utf-8 here once you do that the thing
below here make sure you see this it's
going to change to tf8 and now if we run
the application it should work let's
come down
play yarn and run our thing
and now it is working we are able to
compile our user interface code into
python code and loading that python code
in our own application and this is
really cool we can put in our full name
to make sure that our connection to
slots and signals are working Daniel
gray
occupation is going to be a farmer and
if we submit you see he is a farmer if
we change to plumber
he is going to be a plumber and this is
working exactly like we want and again
the mid of this is to be able to call
the user interface compiler the command
is what we have here make sure you
remember it or have it typed somewhere
where you are able to access it easily
once you have your python codes
generated make sure it is in the correct
encoding at least if you are using
visual studio code once you have it in
the correct encoding you can import the
code in your widget.pi file and create
your class like we do here once you have
your class you will do the necessary
connections to manipulate the user
interface components remember these are
the objects names we have in our
designer file once you have your class
you will create objects of it and you
will play with it however you want we
are going to stop here in this lecture
and I will see you in the next one in
this lecture we are going to look at how
to use the cute resource system and this
is a powerful system that allows us to
bundle files into our python application
so that they can be found easily without
having to need to put them where our
main python binary or script is and we
will explain this concept using this
little application here so we will have
a minus button and a plus button when
you click on minus we will decrease the
number that we have here when you click
on plus we will increment the number and
this is going to be a spinbox component
I don't think we had a chance to talk
about it but you're going to see it as
we go in this chapter here the main
point is to be able to load the icons
for minus and plus here from our QT
resource system in this lecture we will
be doing things manually from QT
designer to show you how to work with
this and here is a simple piece of text
saying the same thing I just said here
but one thing you should keep in your
mind is that the files in your resource
files are going to be compiled into
python code and that's why it is
possible to directly find them where
your main python script is without
having to need to browse through the
file system where your python code is
running and this is really important but
again it's going to incur a price on you
the developer to have to compile your
resource file into python code and
you're going to see that it is really
easy we use a QT resource compiler and
it's really easy you just have to call
the command and you will get a python
file that you can then load into your Pi
side project the workflow we will be
using here is to create the resource
file of course you also need to create
your user interface files you're going
to be needing we will compile the
resource into python code we will import
the python resource file into our own
python application and we will be using
that in our application here here I am
showing you how we will be doing this in
designer so once you have designer
opened you will click on this button
here this is going to pop up this little
widget in this widget you can create a
resource file using the menu here and
you can add the files to that resource
using the menu here I will show you how
to do this in a minute when we hit our
designer instance once you have your
resource file created the file is going
to be named
resource.qrc this is an extension that
Designer understands QT designer I
should say and you will run this command
Pi side 6 Dash RCC you will give it the
resource file you will say that your
output file name is resource underscore
RC Dot py and it is important to follow
this naming convention because other
tools like QT designer are going to be
looking for it so make sure if your file
is resourced to name the output python
file resource underscore RC you
basically have to add an underscore RC
on this then here and this is going to
work once you have your python file that
you generate you will need to import
that in your python project and all you
need to do is say something like this
and you will be able to use it notice
that this is our own class named widget
it's going to be inheriting from our UI
widget file and it will be accessing the
buttons so we are making connections to
our buttons just like you see here and
we will be setting icons to these
buttons and you see we set up the icons
like this and the mid of this is what we
do here to access our images notice the
syntax we use colon backslash images
backslash plus this is because our
images are going to be leaving in a
folder named images and once you follow
this convention here everything is going
to work we have the plus icon we can set
it to our button and our user interface
is going to show up exactly like we want
okay now that you know this we are going
to head over to visual studio code and
play with us a little more okay here we
are in our project the project we work
on is going to be seven resource manual
designer and this is where we're going
to be playing with this the first thing
we need to do is to create our user
interface in designer so let's make sure
we have designer opened open it if it's
not opened for you and we will be
creating a new project or a new file
it's going to be based off widgets here
so let's create this is going to create
our user interface we will be creating
our user interface a lot of times here
because you need to be familiar with us
so let's do this we need two buttons the
first one is going to be on the left the
other one is going to be to the right we
need a spin box and we will be using a
regular spin box why not we will have
the button to the left named minus
button so we need to change the object
name here and we name the other one plus
button
okay the one on the left is minus we can
change the text
let's say minus and say plus to the
right here let's look at the object name
for our spin box it is named spinbox
let's name it spin box with an
underscore because this is our naming
convention and make sure the object name
for the top level widget is widget
because this is our conversion layer
widget and we have our user interface I
think we can apply a horizontal layout
immediately by clicking on the empty
form and clicking this button here and
we can resize this okay to something
like this and we have our application
here okay we have our file here we can
save it let's say file save and we will
browse to a location where we would like
to save this it is in our project here
so we will name it resource or widget.u
I not resource sorry for that so we save
this on our drive and we have this thing
saved once we have this saved we will
also create a resource file and we can
close this now we don't need to close it
because we need an active resource file
to be able to create our resource file
this is unfortunate in a designer so
let's open this again we can go where we
saved it sorry if this is a bit
convoluted but it is what we have to
work with so let's bring this back once
we have this created we can head over to
our designer we will have a little
button like this okay make sure you see
this I am going to click on it it is
going to pop up another window and on
the left here we have the option to
create new resource files so let's click
on this button here that says new
resource file it's going to browse into
my system where I want to save my
resource file I am going to choose this
location here and name it
resource.qrc I think the extension is
going to be put in automatically when I
save the file is going to be saved if I
go back to my location I am going to
have my file where is that where is it
where did I put that file let's try to
hit OK and see if this is actually going
to save my resource file or I put it in
the wrong location yes we have the file
here because we closed that so it must
be designer that was having problems
saving my resource file now that I have
the resource file created I can move
over to the right here okay and add the
prefix a prefix is really like a logical
grouping of files into your resource
system for now don't worry too much
about this click on ADD prefix and take
out everything to have a default prefix
that is to the root of where your
resource file is that's what we are
doing here so let's hit enter this is
going to give us a no prefix then and
once we have a prefix we can add new
files I am going to click on add files
and this is going to browse it to my
location I can go in my images folder
don't worry I will be giving you this
images folder you can use it in your
project you can actually download the
source code and you will get that as
part of what you download select
everything here and open and these
things are going to be added in your
resource file once you hit OK you will
see that these files are going to show
up to the right here and you can right
click and copy path okay and this is
going to give you a path that you can
use in your python code so let's make
sure we open notepad and paste that here
so that you can see it you can see the
path we will be using in our python code
okay now we have two things we have a
user interface file that we need to
compile it to python we also have a
resource file that we need to compile it
to python now we can come out of the
editor the designer editor and come back
to visual studio code and what do we do
we can go to where our project is number
seven here and we can load it into
Visual Studio code and the first thing
we need to do is to compile our user
interface let's view and show the
terminal I think we still have our
Command to compile our widget UI into
python it is right here I just got it by
hitting up up if you don't have it you
can type it if I run it's going to
compile my python file that you see here
and remember to turn this to utf-8 if
you are using visual studio code so
let's do that you already done this from
the last lecture so we are ready to do
this and we need to compile our resource
file into python as well again I will be
giving you the command here I am going
to paste it in pi side 6 Dash RCC you
get to this as part of your Pi side 6
installation and I will give it the
resource file you need to compile you
will say Dash o and say the output file
name the naming like this is important
because your other tooling like designer
are going to be looking for that so make
sure word that you attach an underscore
RC to whatever name you have for your
resource file here and once you have
this you can hit enter this is going to
compile the file this is the output
python file you can see that this is
binary representation for the files that
we have in our resource file
now that we have this lens we can
actually create our python files we will
need a main python file main.py as usual
we also need a widget py file I will put
in my widget py file immediately here
because I don't want to type all this
you can type this if you want but you
can also download the source code and
use it as is here the main point is that
you know how to work with resource files
in your python applications so notice
that we have a squiggle because our
widget file starts with an underscore
okay so UI widget.py that's what we are
importing from we will create our own
widget which is going to inherit Q
widget and UI widget we will set up a
window title we will access our plus
button and minus button and we will be
setting up our slots that are going to
respond whenever something changes in
spin box let's change this to say self
spin box because I think we named our
thing using
let's go back and open recent forms
that's going to be widget UI and our
spin box is named user and underscores
make sure you don't mix these things up
so spin underscore bucks that's the name
spin underscore box that's going to be
our thing here and whenever you click on
plus we will be incrementing the value
in our spin box whenever you click on
minus we will be decrementing the value
in our spin box that's what we are doing
here but the main thing is that we are
setting up an icon that is using things
in our resource file and we are able to
do this because we imported our resource
underscore RC file that we got as a
result of compiling of a resource file
into python make sure you really
understand this now that we have this we
can create our main python file and it
is not going to do anything special it
is just going to import things from our
widget file which is named with an
underscore let's make sure we change
that and we will set up our application
object we will create our widget and we
will show it and everything should work
at this point here before we do that
let's make sure that our UI widget Pi
file is in utf-8 it is so let's try to
run this we are going to go to view and
show terminal and we can go down and go
up up up until we see our Command to run
the code and let's see what we have here
we have a mismatch for a spin box with
camo case here where is it
in our widget Pi file line 12 so let's
go there
widget.py line 12
is trying to use the wrong name for our
spin box let's make sure we fix this and
uh let's try to run again view terminal
and we can clear and try to run and if
we run you see our application is up
here if we click on Plus
and we still have problems with our spin
box sorry for this
but it is something you come across so
no problem here the important thing is
that we can fix it spin box and let's
make sure we run again clear and run
it's going to run if we click plus we
are going to increment if we click on
minus we are going to decrement and
everything is working and the meat of
this is to be able to load these files
from your resource system and some of
you might think why go through the
trouble to use the resource system it is
really important because you don't have
to provide these files where your main
python file is if you deploy this
application to your users and this is
really important make sure you take
advantage of this in your Pi side
applications we are going to stop here
in this lecture and I will see you in
the next one where we're going to be
using QT Creator to create these
resource files here so I will will see
you there in this lecture we are going
to see how to use resources in the QT
resource system from your user interface
files and this is going to save us from
doing what we did here for example by
having to manually set the icons to
buttons we can avoid this kind of thing
and do it right from our user interface
files in this case we will be using
designer so let's head over to visual
studio code and actually set up a
project that is going to help us do that
and another thing I should point out is
that you don't even have to manually
import this file in your python project
because you will have done this from the
user interface file but make sure that
you still have your resource file
compiled into python because the UI file
is going to be looking for that and it
will be looking for a name in conversion
like this from your resource files so
let's head over to visual studio code
and do this okay here we are in our
editor we will be loading resources from
our user interface file and we will be
working in this folder here I think we
can still code from the last project and
use that as our starting point here okay
we have the UI file and the resource
file we also need these images so let's
copy that and put that in our nine
project here once we have this we can
bring this into Visual Studio code by
dragging and dropping here and what we
want to do is to go to our python file
and take out the import we are doing
here we don't need this anymore and we
don't need to set the resources like we
are doing here because our user
interface file is going to take care of
that so let's open our designer file and
again make sure that you do this once
you have a resource file like the
resources that Q RC file we will open
our user interface file in designer so
let's make sure we have designer up and
running designer and we can run it and
we will hop over to the current project
on my file system number nine and drag
and drop the design file here so once I
have this I can click on this button and
I will have a bunch of properties for
this button here but before I do that
let's make sure that I have a resource
file applied to this UI file so what I
can do is come to add a resource file
let's open a resource file that is
already existing so I am going to browse
to the location of my project here on my
system let's do that let's go there
designer number nine that's the current
project and we have a resource file that
we can open here let's open if we open
it it's going to show the images that it
has and this is going to work just fine
let's hit OK and once we do that we will
be seeing our images and the current UI
file is ready to start pulling resources
from this resource file here that's why
we need to do this connection here once
we have this we can click on our minus
button I think we will have an icon
property we can even search by going to
the top here and say icon
okay we will find icon here and once we
have icon we can click to the right here
click on the three dots now we don't
need to click on the three dots we can
click on the downward error here and we
can choose resource once we do that
we're going to click on images and we
can click minus once we do that the
minus icon is going to show up we're
going to repeat the same process on the
plus button click on the down arrow
choose resource click on images and on
the right here you can choose plus and
this is working because we made the
connection between the widget UI file
and the resource file that we have on in
our path here once we have this we can
save so let's save this again and
because we just changed our user
interface file we need to recompile this
into Python and this is something I want
you to be aware of every time you change
your things in your user interface files
you need to recompile them into python
files so that the python side of your
application can pick up those changes so
let's come back to visual studio code we
can really close out of QT designer here
we don't need this anymore we can come
back to visual studio code view our
terminal okay and we can clear and go up
up to compile our user interface file
into our python file and we will be
using the user interface compiler notice
that we don't even need to recompile the
resource file because we already had
that but if you don't have a resource
file or if it is the first time you set
up your resource file you will need to
compile that into python code I am going
to show you why in a minute once we see
our newly generated UI widget that Pi
file if we go there the first thing I
want you to notice is that the the
encoding has changed back to utf-16
because this is a newly generated file
so let's make sure we go back and change
this back to utf-8 okay we need to do
that and another thing I want you to see
is that this file is going to be doing
the import for you because it is the one
that is doing the setting of the icons
on our buttons so make sure you still
have your resource file compiled into
python code and make sure you use this
name and conversion here you see that QT
designer or the user interface compiler
to be exact is looking for this and you
need to follow this conversion for
things to fall in place and work so our
python file should be clean now it is
not important things it is not setting
icons but our application should still
work let's go to view the terminal and
clear and run if we run we should see
this coming up here if we click on plus
it's going to increase comment if we
click on minus it is going to decrement
and everything is working as we want
this is really all I wanted you to see
in this lecture how to connect your user
interface files with the resource files
make sure that whenever you change
something in the user interface file you
recompile to python for the python side
of your application to pick up the
changes and use them I am going to stop
here in this lecture in the next one I
will show you how to do the same from
cute Creator I'll see you there
in this lecture we are going to design a
slightly involved Q made window
application which is going to be using
resources intensively we're going to
have a chance to play with the menus and
toolbars and we will be able to use the
images that are coming from a resource
file that is going to be attached to our
user interface file we're going to be
building something like this so this is
going to be our application here you can
see that we have a bunch of menus we
have a toolbar here and we are using
icons that we will be pulling from our
resource file down in the middle this is
going to be a central widget for our
main window and it is going to be a text
edit component and we will set up this
entire user interface in q2designer and
use it in Visual Studio code on the
python side so let's do this
here we are in our working folder we
will be working in this folder number
11. you can see that it is an empty
folder the first thing we want to do is
to open cute designer and actually set
up our user interface in this place here
let's do that QT designer
and it is going to be a main window
project that we want to set up so make
sure you select main window here and
create and this is going to give us a
main window that we can play with make
sure you know the name of the top level
widget in this case it's going to be
named main window this is okay and we
want to add a bunch of menus just like
we saw so we can say file here by
clicking and typing let's look at our
design we have a file edit and help
let's do that we're going to say edit
and help
let's see what we have in our file menu
in the file menu we will have a quick
action so let's put in quit
okay and you can see that when you
double click on the place that says type
here you're going to be adding in an
action let's go to edit we will put in
copy
cut paste we can undo but before we do
let's add the separator and then undo
and redo and help we can say about
and about QT
I am going to show you how to pop up a
bunch of dialogues that show information
here and I think we have our user
interface if we come down I think we can
say add toolbar this is going to give us
a place where we can drag and drop
thanks so let's go down here in the user
interface where it says action editor
and in here we can actually add a bunch
of actions so you can see that we
already have many actions so we have
action quit copy cut and paste what we
want to do is to but before we add icons
to these actions we actually need to add
a resource file so let's go to Resource
browser here and click you already know
how to add the resource we will be
adding a new resource file to this
project it's going to be saved and let's
go somewhere on a drive here 11 here
that's the folder the name of the file
is going to be resource nothing
complicated here dot QRC and that's
going to be our resource I am going to
copy a folder of images that I will be
using in this project here it is going
to be available once you download the
source code for this lecture here so
let's go in the current project and add
in our images folder and we can come
back to designer and once we have the
resource we will be needing to add a
prefix click on ADD prefix here take out
everything like we did earlier and now
you can add files if we go in images we
are going to select everything and add
all these files here and if we hit OK
these files should now be available for
a use in the project here now we can
come back to the action editor and
double click on action quit if we do we
will have the option to set an icon
let's choose resource and go in images
and we will choose the quit icon here so
let's hit OK and if we do okay again the
icon is going to show up let's do the
same for copy let's choose resource
images copy where is the copy icon it is
right here so let's select that hit okay
we are going to go to cat and do the
same choose resource images cut icon
that's what we want and hit OK we want
to paste choose resource images paste
and okay we want undo resource images
and do where is undo undo is right here
let's select it and hit OK we want to
redo resource images redo icon after
that we have about let's click OK first
about let's go choose resource images
about that's going to be this icon here
which is black we hit OK and about QT
let's go to Icon choose resource images
and about QT the orange one and we can
hit okay now that we have this we can
actually drag and drop actions on the
toolbar and this is going to be really
cool you see it shows up here you can
right click and say add separator okay
and then we can do copy cat and paste
okay this is something we can do once we
do this we can even add another
separator okay and after we do that we
are going to do undo and redo okay we
can do something like this
another thing we can do is to add the
text edit component okay we can drag it
and drop it here and we can click in
some empty space and use a vertical
layout for example to make the text edit
fill our user interface and at this
point I really think we have everything
we need for our user interface file and
because it is automatically loading the
resources we don't need to manually
import the resource file all we need to
do is compile our user interface to
Python compile the resource to Python
and we will be able to set up a main
window python file that is going to be
using these things on the visual studio
code side or the pi side if I can say it
like that so let's save this file here
let's save and we will be given the
option to choose where we want to save
it it is going to go where we are saving
out of files so let's go to that
location and choose this guy the name is
going to be main window in lowercase
dot UI and if we save it should be
available in our current working folder
we have the resource file we have the
main window file we can close out of
designer if we want but for now what we
want to do is to load this guy into
Visual Studio code so that's going to be
our project here so let's drag and drop
inside of Visual Studio code we will
have our thing here and we want to
compile these guys so let's show a
terminal window and we can hit up up to
go into our Command history we will see
how to compile our user interface file
we just need to change the name here I
am going to change this to main window
to UI main window
main window
this is what we want if I do this this
is going to generate my main window file
let's go up again and try to find that I
wanted to compile the resource file we
have a
resource.qrc we don't really need to
change anything here this is going to
compile our file we need to go to the
main window python file and change the
encoding to utf-8 if you remember
correctly so let's change this to utf-8
and now we have everything we need we
can start creating our python files we
can create the main python file we can
also create the main window python file
and now that we have this and what we
will do is just put in the code to use
our generated python file main window or
UI underscore main window Pi file we are
importing the file here and we are going
to be inherit from that file as we do
here in the Constructor we do really
nothing special here we are just taking
an application parameter and that's
going to be what we use to kill the
application when the user triggers the
quit action and down here you see that
we do connections to our actions so we
say action quit when it's triggered we
are going to quit the application when
the action to copy is triggered we will
be running our copy slot which is what
we have here and we do all these
connections here there is really nothing
special and in about we will be putting
out a message box that is going to say
something that is just going to be
saying something here and when the user
triggers the about cute action what we
will do is show a message from our Q
application class here this is something
you can do the main thing here is ready
to be able to build your user interface
from designer and be able to bring those
files into use in your Pi site
application like we are doing here in
Visual Studio code now that we have our
main window we can go to the main python
file and bring everything together
nothing complicated we are just
importing our main window file the main
window cluster is in there we are
creating an object of it and showing it
and kicking off the event Loop here
again let's make sure that we compiled
our resource it is we compiled our UI
main window python file it is using
utf-8 this looks good let's show our
terminal and try to run the application
and if we are lucky everything is going
to work and it is going to be really
cool let's try to run okay so it seems
we don't have an action named about
underscore cute let's go back to our
designer file and make sure that our
action is named about QT yes it is named
about QT and it seems we are doing
something bad in our main window python
file so let's go about QT let's take out
the underscore let's try to run again
terminal
clear if we try to run now it is going
to run if we quit we should be able to
quit the application if we run it again
we should be able to see it you see we
see our icons in our toolbar if we go to
file and quit it is going to go away you
already know how to work with Q main
window by the way if we edit we can copy
cut paste and do redo and for example we
can DDD here and do it's going to go
away we can copy let's say the sky
is blue you can copy this through the
toolbar and we can even paste and paste
and paste and paste this is going to
work we can undo it's going to go away
we can redo it's going to come back we
can even cut out everything here and
paste you see we are really able to use
this application and this is really cool
let's use the help menu about it's going
to show a message box that we triggered
in our code if we do about QT it is
going to show information about the QT
version that was used to compile this
application this is really cool and this
is all we set out to do in this lecture
showing you a slightly practical way to
use the resource system to your
advantage and again this is going to be
really cool because all these resource
files are going to be available to our
application without having to recopy
these images when you deploy your
application and this is really cool I am
going to stop here in this lecture and I
will see you then this one
congratulations on hitting the end of
the course here you have learned a lot
in terms of using qt4 python to build
cute widgets applications that you can
run on Windows Mac and Linux now that
you have these fundamentals you may be
asking what's next well you just
scratched the surface when it comes to
using Q2 widgets to build applications
that can run on different platforms and
a few other topics I would recommend is
learning about events the graphics view
framework which allows you to build
interactive applications this is
actually one of my favorite topics
intuitive you can learn about networking
you can learn about databases you can
learn about threads there is really no
shortage of things you can learn about
in QT another thing you can learn about
is qml which is another API to build a
graphical user interfaces that are fluid
and dynamic to run on mobile and
embedded this is a really hot topic in
QT and I would recommend taking a Twist
a moment meant to look at this because
if you are serious about QT you are
probably going to run into qml so that's
something you might want to look at we
have a few courses on qml if you are
interested you can check them out and
really what I would recommend is to try
and think about things that interest you
the most or things you think that you
are likely to meet in your career as a
developer focus on those things learn
how to do those things in QT and your
learning experience is going to be much
better this is really all I had to share
in this lecture again congratulations on
hitting the end thanks for giving me the
opportunity to be your instructor if you
are interested in many of our other
courses be sure to check them out I am
going to stop here in this lecture and I
will see you next time